hello everyone good morning well i just woke up like i think at i don't know whatever time i wrote in the chat i woke up at like around 12 15 i know already the eye bags i know what i know what what's coming up i i know what my fate lies uh yeah no i brushed my i brushed my teeth i didn't eat lunch though but to be fair i i made spicy nudes uh spicy noodles we're just like spicy dudes my spicy i call them spicy nudes every time um because i i have the humor of a 13 year old But I made spicy noodles,
you know, Bulldog noodles.
I, uh,
I, I had, I made spicy Bulldog noodles.
I just remember not to say the, uh, my favorite term, um, in public.
Um, at like five in the morning, uh,
because i was just like i'm hungry so i i made it at five in the morning so i don't think i need to eat lunch right now yeah i was like i couldn't sleep so i was like i want some spicy noodles i was just late night cooking at five in the morning um um truly yeah i'm an adult with spam too I love making it with spam.
I ran out of eggs.
I had like I had One more egg in my fridge, but expired on August 2nd So I don't think it was it would have been a good idea to you.
I was tempted, but I'm like no your life's already a mess Stokey.
I don't I don't think you should try and Try and and and make expired
let it hash because I thought I would use it before it expired that was like oh expired August 2nd oh and it's still in the fridge I didn't throw it out yet I'll throw it out whenever it's it's time whenever I feel like it's time it's Just one egg.
It's just...
But yes, I know how, like, yesterday I was like, maybe I'll do Epic Mickey.
Maybe I'll do a white-off.
And then you see that, by the way, my manager made the waiting room because I couldn't stay up for the thumbnail.
For those who don't know, my thumbnail maker is EU.
So, uh, she, uh, so like, uh, sometimes I'm not awake when the thumbnail's done.
So then I was like, I can't stay up.
So, um, I asked my manager, I was like, can you upload the waiting room for me?
Uh, whenever, whenever the thumbnail's done, and then I can go, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
um um but yes and then then you know and then boof marvel rivals rake dokey this is an epic mickey that you said you do yeah i was like i didn't really feel like playing epic mickey today i was like what do i and i was like looking through games yesterday and be like what do i want to play um because i want to make because you know there's no actual schedule right now since like i'm not gonna like post a public schedule um i guess like i'm not gonna post a public schedule like like with only two days left of the week so i was like okay that's to be something i can sort of like get away with so um so i was like you know what i really feel like playing rivals ring i actually haven't been playing marvel rivals ring in a long time like um i've been okay i was uh I'll show you guys the record later but literally um I have like very little play time um like uh for a bit so uh I didn't even play the last season so last season right like literally says zero matches played um and everything so
I haven't played in a while I haven't played when Phoenix came out so so I was like you know what you know I just visited the studio and I got I have a craving a craving for some uh for some rank uh so yeah so decide today i was just like you know let's fucking do it i'll just play some rival rival's rank and just see how it goes it's been such a long time there's no decay by the way um because i always make sure that i end in eternity by the end of the season that i end eternity so when because there's no like mid-season there's for those who don't know there's no mid-season decay so they don't like they don't set you back mid-season so you're staying in the same season so i always make sure at the end of every season that i end at eternity so i don't decay that much that's like my loophole i just make sure i don't decay that much by the end of the season uh so um so when the new season comes out then i don't come back and see myself in silver or some shit um so so that's what i've
been doing so uh i did play a little i played a little bit yesterday um just to like de-rest like i played nine games yesterday which is not you know i played nine games yesterday so uh uh uh so like um you know i still i still you know i try to like de-rest myself before this stream um and um and it's still i don't know i think it's because i was in diamond and i guess like i like i'm grandmaster yellow right now so after after today's stream i'll call the plumber guys after today's stream i'll call the plumber
I'll call him after today's stream, everyone.
Do not worry.
Do not be afraid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, that's why.
Okay, but I do have some funny clips to show you guys.
All right, let me see.
Also, I forgot to say why I also think I might have to visit a tempo.
Sorry.
Why I have to visit a tempo.
to wash the bad luck.
I forgot to say the plane had dessert but the only dessert they had was strawberry ice cream.
And for those who don't know, I am allergic to strawberry.
So I was so sad because I was like, yippee, ice cream!
And then they like gave me strawberry haggendazs.
I was like, do you have anything else?
I'm allergic.
And they're like, oh, we don't, sorry.
And I was like, oh.
Tokyo to Canada flight.
They both had strawberry ice cream.
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
So I was like, no dessert for you, Doki.
And then no dessert.
And it had to be strawberry ice cream.
Of all, like it could have been anything else.
Like, honestly, they could have given me fruit.
And I should be fine.
As long as there's no strawberry.
the fact that the only dessert they had in stock on that plane was fucking strawberry ice cream i i was so disappointed so sad so i was like i was like i can't believe i can't believe this like happened to me i can't believe it also on that plane i realized um i realized that 100 if i was bit by a zombie I will absolutely infect everybody overseas I because I was like the only one that was like sort of you know I was sick you're on the plane and people could like hear me cough and everything I was wearing like a face mask though um you know uh um and everything but I was like coughing and stuff and I was like thinking oh man I think I'd be like one of those infected that would be that would have like got bit and I'd be like I gotta take a plane ride back to Canada.
The doctors there can fix me up.
Like, I was like, I don't want to be, I don't want to be sick in this, in this country.
I want to be back home.
I want to, I don't want to be in like a place that I don't live.
And if I'm going to die, I'm going to die at home.
Zero.
Yeah.
I, I be like, I, and I just get on the plane and just like get in didn't turn into the zombie on the plane i felt like the i was like i was like i want i want to turn in the comfort of my own home like i'm meanwhile i have to choose between shooting my zombie oshi or doing humanity papa smirk thank you for the super chat thank you thank you actual pioneers i'm just i was like i i was like thinking about like yeah no i no i was like thinking like no i would do this i would come back i would bring the virus to i would be the one that brings the virus airborne to a different country like you know how like what was it 28 days or later like all the zombie apocalypse and the 20 what was it like x date like um like the 28 years and or later or 28 years later series the zombie apocalypse it's all stuck in the united kingdom i'd be the one that bringing it out of the uk i i consider everyone keeps saying it's like oh yeah all the all the zombie like the the infection is just stuck in on the
united kingdom and in the rest of the world just watching i'm thinking like i'd be the one that bring it out of the uk
the problem you see i know i'm the problem okay i'm it's not like i'm like no guys i would never do that guys i would make sure to protect humanity i but that i'm you see i'm i'm i'm like up front about it i'm not hiding behind anything i will bring it to a different country
i i know you straight in a virus jockey So for the downfall of humanity, see, I wouldn't lie about it, you know, like, it would be like, guys, no, I would never, I would make sure, I would make sure to, like, stay confined.
I wouldn't take a plane and try to get out while I know I'm infected, guys, I would never do that.
But no, I'm true, though, I'm very upfront, guys, I'm very upfront.
I would absolutely doom humanity if I wanted to, like, be back home.
I will hide the bite marks because I'd be thinking, don't worry, I can fix, in my head, I'd be like, I can fix this, guys.
I'd be like, don't worry, I think I'm one of the, I could be the 0.1% chance that I am one of those immune people, and we couldn't find out unless we weighed it out, guys.
I can take it, exactly, exactly.
happen it could happen i could be the 0.1 guys it i hate uh it's just yeah it's just the cold uh yeah i am if i am a little bit laggy it's because of the marvel rivals thing i just need to make sure i'm streaming it now okay don't worry let me uh change this and then it should be better
now it should be fine um but yes you can see that i've only played nine matches um and then zero here
can't believe we have to delete joki immediately in the event of a zombie apocalypse next scene thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh so you see here literally zero times played um and then but like i i did end in eternity though i did say i did say i would try to end in eternity um before before the season ends and then right here it's like zero matches played and then i played a little bit here so i don't have to be at least diamond okay wait wait i have some funny clips to show you guys give me a sec um let me let me show you guys all right uh Let's see.
But history.
Okay.
I swear to God it's pretty shitty.
I swear.
It's very shitty.
Okay.
I think it's...
Oh yeah, it's this one.
No, it's GM.
I'm terrorizing GM lobbies now.
I think it's this one, right?
No, it's not.
they're like almost there god damn it where's my shilly clip it was it was pretty shilly it was a little silly was it this no no it's not is it this one no oh my gosh i don't remember was it this one was it this one no okay guys give me a sec i swear to god it's very shilly it's worth it it's Very shilly.
Oh, it's this one.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
I have two shilly ones.
I have two silly ones to show you.
Okay.
All right, here.
So, I was like, okay.
I was like, wait a minute.
minute i'm opening a portal so i was like oh portal time give me a sec guys don't worry i got this
that's called game sense baby that's i heard i'm opening a portal see fucking game sense this is This is what separates me from the fuck other diamond play.
Where does he say it?
Where does he say I'm opening a portal?
Right here.
Not here.
Okay, apparently it doesn't give the sound cue again.
But there you go.
Bam!
I'd be so pissed.
No stalling for you.
also all right i'll show you guys another clip i'll show you the sad strange was fuming all right this is another clip i okay like i know some of you might be very disappointed
when you see when you see when you see this but let me explain let me explain i was playing you know so because I was playing off stream in my head I was like no one will know
but um now people will know because it was such a funny clip it was such a funny clip in the end people had to know
a clip was pretty funny so i have to show it now all right i think it's is it this one i think it's this one yeah and then i have to i tell i told on myself um oh my god which one was it i'm trying to remember like the map names and everything but is it this one no this one was when people be like had like 3 games out of the 9 games I played three of those games they voted for surrender so like I nearly it was like after the first round they voted for surrender so it was like I didn't even have to play the game technically like it's like what I like after first round they're like we we quit and I was like okay all right that's cool okay I will show you Okay,
guys, okay.
I know, like, okay, guys, look, I can explain.
I got lazy on this game.
I got a little lazy.
Okay, that I can explain.
Okay, so, so, okay, but it was a funny clip, okay.
It was pretty funny.
All right, so I was like, oh, shit, goodbye, I guess.
I don't think we're gonna live this.
So, so I was like, alright, I guess I'll leave.
And then I was like, bro, get the fuck off me, get off!
I was literally being chased, dude, look at this, three people!
Three people were chasing me!
And I was like, alright, hello guys, and then I looped back.
I was like, alright, I lived.
I lived.
I literally had zero.
Zero damage, too, by the way.
But zero damage.
Okay.
I'll show you what this looked like.
It's actually really funny what it looks like.
In the outside POV, it's actually pretty funny.
If you do free cam.
Look at this.
Like...
It's like...
It's like a little...
There's like a little chase like look look at how everybody's trying to kill me.
I was like, excuse me Like leave me alone And that wasn't Like that wasn't the only instance that like watch this look Like like look at this
Like whoa Hello, I'm still alive.
Hello The video music, and then I came back, I was like, hello everybody, I'm alive.
Okay, there was another instance, it was like, um, Wolverine enters the battle.
Okay, so there was another instance, I think it was here, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, I'm going to double check if it's this one, because this happened multiple times.
I was like, oh shit, oh, they're alive.
That's fine.
Yeah, there it is.
There it is.
Wait, is this one?
Our cloak was not having a good time, by the way.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
Is this where I get chased?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
And I was like, goodbye.
Goodbye.
And then... Wait, no, it wasn't this.
It wasn't this.
Where was it?
Where was it that I, like, lived?
God, gross behavior!
There was an instance where, like, I was being chased here.
They were really, they were pretty bad.
But to be fair, I was not supposed to be in this Elo.
To be fair, I was absolutely not supposed to be here.
So, like, it was...
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
This is it right here.
I was like, sorry cloak and then the spider-man came over So I was like we my people need me and then I was like where the fuck did the Thor came from and then I got solo Upton.
I was like, and he's still chasing me.
I was like, I was like, where did the Thor come from?
So I was just like, bro, what the fuck?
And I'm just like, I don't, man, I, I'm not supposed to be in this Elo, man.
I'm like, I'm just like, I playing that game, you realize, like, oh, I, I did not play for a while, but even I knew I wasn't supposed to be here.
Get over here.
Where'd she go?
Yeah.
All right.
inviting a player to play because I don't want to solo queue despite like how much I love Marvel Rivals rank I just like how much I love rank I don't want to solo queue guys hold on if I have to de-rust so I don't want to be a leader so um oh hello like thank you for the red thank you thank you okay you are the leader all right i'm just waiting for oh wait okay i'll show you guys okay they made this new change they made this new change in the in the game and it's one of the best changes ever and i'll show you what they did okay you guys watching
Now we can wait and...
We can...
Igniting the time.
Why am I not in the lobby?
Oh, there I...
We got a game.
Why?
Yes.
So in the waiting screen.
you can put on emotes while you wait no i want what a great thing to join in all right what do i want to play i want to play loki or luna okay we have three dps players but that's fine that's fine this is obviously the most optimal Update they've ever done.
I think that makes this game, like, an 11 out of 10.
Alright.
Emma.
Why Emma?
Why not?
Torch.
I'm fucking banning Torch next.
Be right back.
Why would you bleach your eyes?
It is a beautiful thing.
You society gave us ask so why not use it why not appreciate the beauty that God gave us he knows venom knows what he has so he is he he's giving us the people what they want what to play I don't know if I don't play it dude I don't play Loki just to get the Lord icon because I'm literally just missing I'm missing I have Lord Icon on Mantis,
Kloog, Invis, and Luna.
I'm just missing it on Loki.
I...
Yeah, this is GM Elo.
So, like, um, shit, Lo.
I'm sorry for your GM.
Pick up!
Which support you?
I'm fucking...
I guess I have to play Luna.
I...
Oh my god, we have a Spider-Man.
All right.
I have to warm up.
I haven't not played anything.
I've not played anything.
I didn't want...
I never warm up anyway.
But it's going to be interesting.
GM is way higher than it used to be.
Okay.
I don't know.
For me, I was playing in GM lobbies like yesterday.
like people were a bit messy but I also heard they removed stacking so a lot of people who got boosted by six stacking plus or like not plus but you know what I mean a lot of people that got like heavily carried and stacking for oh my god how do you die okay look okay who like heavily abused it but would only get to like the lower egos like i guess like gm celestia felt hard don't worry i got you okay i have to don't worry i got you oh my my god don't worry i still got you don't worry everybody i'm a healer
okay that's fine it's fine that i missed that um but i know there's like a lot of like super inflated players that are dropping hard right now because they got rid of stacking and yeah because i know like in the past people would six stack to like celestia i want to eat all the guy so like so like and it was so easy to abuse that whoa oh my god that's a combo don't worry i think cloak will oh don't worry i think cloak will Don't worry.
Okay, never mind Oh shit.
Okay, I'm alive.
Hello.
They have a scarlet witch?
I live through one disaster just to have to go through another.
I, okay.
I literally live through like hell.
Get through Scarlet Witch.
That's fucked up.
Also, I think there's Spider-Man.
Don't be toxic, but I think Spider-Man is not a very good player.
Here's the born again.
But I just think, obviously.
Just a theory.
It's just a theory.
Okay, I just saw that happen.
But it's still just a...
Oh!
Okay, that, okay, why did our cloak not alt?
Why did our cloak not alt?
Cloak, you had four second cooldown!
You had four seconds to peer!
Oh my god, four seconds!
The fucking sound cue was so early!
Like...
Saving it for next game.
The sound kill- it takes like four seconds to charge that up!
He fucking is saying, like, a fucking novel!
There is a novel going on!
Okay, I don't know if, like, that can kill anything, though.
Please!
Oh!
I- Please!
No, he did!
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't save me from a fucking nuke.
Never mind.
I can't live through a nuke.
I wonder if she...
Never mind.
Nothing can save me from that.
Already just... I'm having so much fun.
I'm having the time of my life right now.
You're winning though.
Hey guys, I'm winning.
I'm winning.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Can live through a nuke noted.
If she alted, you wouldn't panic and walk into the 100% cloak attack is false.
Exactly.
It's never my fault, guys.
No bikini, Luna Snow.
You need to pay real money for that.
I couldn't use my... Wait, actually?
Do I have it?
On the account?
I don't know.
Sometimes, I think one time I got a bug where, but like, I think like you need to pay, because you need to buy the Battle Pass or whatever.
So, no, it's a different currency.
I have the blue currency, but I don't have the yellow one, because that one requires real money.
I have the blue, but the the bikini one requires that requires me to actually use um okay give me a sec there's a wolverine requires me to actually use real money because you have to buy the battle plat pass yeah you need the luna you need the the battle pass for it yeah we're back in the marvel rival's minds cosmic thank you for the super chat thank you what converted oh my god wait wait how wait teach me teach me no they always oh my god wait how many deaths does he have okay teach me they've always had wolverine
it's fine i will limit i'll make sure you live don't worry your hero is here do not worry do not whoa
Okay, I'm working a little bit.
I didn't...
Why?
Of course it's me.
I...
The hero died like a hero.
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
The hero's coming back.
Please just live.
Just...
Oh my god.
There we go.
Don't worry, the hero is here.
I will waste my shift so I don't...
don't have to do more heals.
Jesus Christ, he's just fucking... Oh my God!
Oh my God!
To be fair, I kept him alive as long as I could there.
That was crazy how long I kept that man alive.
That's actually crazy how oh my God.
Okay, let me stand on my own cloak.
Okay, this is I die though 100% this is what I did the most I could look you get the web and you get the web and he dies he does it's fine it's we had 99 uh we had 99 it's he's gonna live See, look at that.
I told you.
I would never lie about that.
Jesus Christ.
How many...
Okay.
We still have... We still have point!
We still have point, guys!
Let's go!
Come on!
Look!
We... I... I don't... Oh my god, it's fine.
It's fine.
Three, two, one.
There we go.
We're so fine.
That's... Fuck you, I... Fuck you!
Fuck you, it's not as cool now!
Oh!
Oh my god, it's okay.
It's okay.
His sacrifice, I will never forget what he did for us.
Okay, the one freeze I missed, though.
The one freeze I missed.
Nice.
We did it!
We won!
I hit every single freeze.
for that.
We did it.
That's my hero.
Look, I told you.
I told you I'm a hero.
I told you guys.
I'm a hero.
Look at that.
Okay, the Spider-Man with the AK was not very inspiring.
Not gonna lie.
no and it's okay not all heroes not our heroes um get that um get that attention you know we gotta be incognito you know you're friendly a neighborhood jokie bird uh oh oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you are you okay jokie i'm playing my rival design this is only my first game system not all heroes were capes exactly oh yeah this is like the new thing that they added uh the spider-man okay anyway so this is the newest feature so basically um when you're waiting you can i wish the only thing they can improve in this is if they add if you can add more characters onto the custom here into the hero screen so now now you can you can put on any emote you want while you wait you can have your little you can have your little on a dj session which hero do you think you want to be today all right oh my god the instant lock spider man i can i play low key now this is a good low key though hey what's up team i'm gonna swap off if we want to try that little mantis group um team up
situation i can do that oh i'm lagging like my not me but well why is am i lagging here okay maybe i should all right i'm gonna close some chrome stuff maybe it's chrome and just and just swap
all right and then take out bp here no sure i'll play it oh okay i'll ban sila you said all right don't ban him who do you want to take out maybe emma or something sila i'll close one of my tabs i think i might have too many tabs guys maybe i'm not sure yet i may or may not have too many tabs all right do you Do I want me to go Wolf or do you want me to go Heels?
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
Do you, can you play Luna well?
I could play Luna or I could play Mantis for the team up with Loki.
I wanna be Loki.
Poopy Scoopy, do you want a duo?
Who's Poopy?
Poopy, Scoopy, Poopy, Scoopy and Wooply, Gooply.
I do need a tank though.
I spent that's a good that's a good name that's a good name what a name poopy scoopy do you want to do oh you know what this is this map I thought it was a different map can I get a match made in highly unserious poopy scoopy and wooply dooply that's how I want to eat it to go the owner's name I hope dupe combo is actually insane oh my gosh why am i lagging so much yes or no that's weird okay yes i can do it all right let's see it that's fine
i don't know why that i'm lagging here but i like i'm not lagging in game it's literally just me
later oh shit I have to reload because I'm not paying attention oh goodbye I am pissed oh goodbye blade oh goodbye everybody goodbye guys I ain't fucking going through that.
Can someone else go tank and let me go wolf?
Take out Eddie Groot.
Can one of our three DPS swap off?
I mean, I'll put it all.
I know how to play it.
They also have a name more so I don't know how effective dive is going to be.
Then don't fucking play dive!
If you think dive is not in, don't play dive!
Oh.
There's like 300 people on us here.
Alright, you know what time it is?
It's time for me to retreat.
I'm not looking to be toxic, but I'm about to swap the DPS if we can't get first.
We have a key.
We have a key, I don't know, we have Moon Knight.
We have very little range.
I mean, to be fair, we have Moon Knight, so...
I mean, I have...
Oh,
I'm fine.
Oh, my God.
Hello, everybody.
Okay, use your...
Oh, my God!
Use your...
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay!
I... Okay...
I don't know.
I thought poopy scoopy would alt i she can alt in that i i'm i'm so confused i'm i'm so confused i i am so confused poopy scoopy poopy scoopy please
i'm not all right once i get close enough please please a poopy scoopy i'm i'm saving for you because you have a faster reaction time than me okay thank god thanks fucking god
thank god okay okay there we go poopy scoopy did it poopy has done it
thank god there we go there we go It all worked out somehow.
It really did.
Good job, Boopie Scoopie.
Good job.
It all worked out.
I'm going to try to ult on Mantis when she ults.
I'm not the best at Loki, so I like to use it to practice.
Especially if in this Elo, I can practice, I mean, not Loki.
I can practice Loki here.
I feel like they're going to soon so I'm gonna try and just in case I'll use it to push up too there you go I have to do that he lives he lives oh my god I didn't okay they're just gonna use Okay.
That's awkward.
He got...
Woofley, can you go tank and let me go DPS please?
I mean, all right, you know what?
Oh, he doesn't know.
Imagine telling...
Telling a...
Imagine a GM player telling a pro player to get off DPS.
That's crazy.
He doesn't know.
Bro!
Bro, my bro, my dude, my dude.
There we go.
We might not live this.
We do.
Because I'm just that good.
You're fucked.
That's how you play support, bitch!
The last critical information.
I thought it was Spider-Man.
his money shirt he doesn't have after everything i did he doesn't heal me it's so sad great play but i got betrayed i know a play of that century why okay a play of the century but it doesn't matter
Don't worry Don't worry, I got this, I think That got root Okay, guys, I think it's not a It might not be a A Wolverine thing Just a maybe I'm not sure yet I'm, oh my god I can't even copy I can't even copy Feels for me but not brings me and prone not for you don't get it the gm they healed me i'm dead oh this is bad where is the invisible women where is she how do i come i can't copy because i see no support oh my god there was i can't copy!
She jumped in!
Why did she jump in?
Loki, you're just sitting in the portal with your alt and...
There was no one to copy.
Alright, cloak jumped in.
And died.
Alright, so let's get a winning cop.
Flying in the air is not gonna work against Punisher.
Can we go maybe rocket and... There's no No way.
They're asking for a rock.
Now they want.
Like, I was like, how do I copy?
How do I copy?
I was like, where's my cloak?
Where the fuck is my cloak?
Okay, we're going Adam.
We'll do Adam, Luna.
I shine in darkness.
Yeah, I was like, I was not the weak link here.
There's no way.
I literally saved us from so many things.
I was like, there's no way you're blaming me when I had such good lamps that's actually crazy imagine being like i'm i'm gm but like i'm pretty sure i play better than this pro player like
marvarez was never changed never changed don't worry now i have wait shit wait what i only played okay one you have to stop them from securing the mission area like i'm like what do you mean my all requires me to copy how do i copy when i can't when i can't find people i got bucky too how am i not getting healing okay i was gonna say How am I not feeling any heals there?
Because I'm like, I'm pretty sure all I have to do is just exist in his LOS.
Be careful.
Alright, we raised him.
Okay, that was just a hell-married task, because I hope that...
I was hoping that I would bump into something.
He's pulling.
Shoot.
Goodbye.
I had to reload.
If I didn't have to reload, he'd live.
If I...
That's actually unfortunate.
Rocket, please!
Puppy!
Jump down!
On front, please, please, please, please.
Oh my god.
He literally didn't jump down.
I...
Oh my...
Who killed our rocket?
Oh my god, he didn't jump down!
I was looking for one of these.
Oh, sweet.
why did he jump down to me i wasn't gonna guys i i think poopily scoopily might be a bad player i don't oh my god okay that's fine that's us
okay we delete that here there was double Double Punisher.
There was no way we can live through that.
There was no way.
There was no way I was gonna live through that.
With Double Punisher, there was no fucking way.
But his name, at least his name is funny.
You know, at least, you know, at least his name is funny.
But I literally think that is...
We definitely have to avoid somebody.
Maybe the Spider-Man.
Please tell me you have all...
What?
Does he not have all?
Uh...
I didn't think he was gonna go there.
Wait, he had all!
It's so difficult for me.
He had all!
It is what it is.
Good try, everyone.
Because I was like...
Just don't understand our picks against three shooters.
We have one diver.
Okay.
I mean, that was me just trolling there.
I...
I think this guy's actually 12.
I think this man's actually 12.
I...
Like, too...
I think...
How is he...
Wait, he is!
He's a Lord of Rockies!
Okay, wait.
I need to know who...
Who are you avoiding?
Okay.
I need to ask who is avoiding so we can coordinate.
I'm not wasting avoid slots.
Who are you avoiding?
Okay.
Avoid!
Snap and Noah, please!
Okay.
Avoid.
And...
Okay.
Okay, this is as, did you avoid the rocket?
Because he, he did so many things.
Can we, I just need to know, has the rocket, I can't even name one thing, like, um, their game, The name was destined their gameplay was not Like I can't even like list all the things he did He did so many things Like I just can't even list it There was just too many Poopy scoopy will miss you You don't understand
You don't understand There were so many things to list There Should we add Poopy Scoopy on the...
We're on the bad word list.
Can we see...
Alright.
Oh my god, he has it.
He is my Elo right now.
Oh, he is in tears.
Alright.
Let us...
Oh my god.
You know, he...
Wait, he's been hard-stucked GMs since season 1?
I'm so sorry.
792 games played!
How?
Seven?
Okay, that was the day he peaked Celestial.
Okay, but...
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I'm sorry.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
He's been in this Elo for a long time.
He's been here for a while.
Um...
he is a war veteran he's been through it all like the moon i shine in darkness now who am i gonna vanish from that's that was i that was so crazy to see that he's must be booked up bro yes but he's still there he's still there he's still
the awareness I'm just saying the awareness after that many games in the same Elo that you've been in since season one.
Like, what did you expect from Poopy Scoopy?
I was, it was just impressive.
It was very impressive.
Don't be jealous, Doki.
You'll never be good as Poopy.
scooply simple-minded thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i just didn't expect it oh this guy really didn't want ooply dooply to play blade
i don't know
i feel like i'm learning
okay oh maybe that's why okay 240.
wait my fps cap um got reset okay there you go what did you learn i learned i learned that that not not everybody deserves your rank maybe maybe that's why like my skin suits lagging a little
240 there you go just maybe all right I learned that some people should not play shooters yeah that's right cut off their hands all I'm saying maybe some people should just have oh wait there's a sword here I'm a little worried I'm gonna go this way just cuz like just in case you know that guy's one I don't have to worry right wait what don't worry that's the last freeze You go back up,
Blade.
Not with you.
I freeze to kill them all.
I want to play Loki.
I want my Lord out, God.
Okay, like, people are so, like, it's so fucking dumb.
They're like, oh, oh, why don't you do it?
Because, like, I would play Loki, but then they'll be like, oh, you have Lord on Luna.
Why don't you play Luna?
I was like, and I'm like, because I want to play Loki.
I'm in this elo, it doesn't mean I don't play other support.
Like, they just assume just because you don't have a lord icon that you're bad at the support.
Okay.
I might need help, though.
Oh my god, okay, I have to use this just because, or we die, or, or we die.
Okay, that's fine.
We might have used all our support logs, but that's fine.
We can build it, I believe.
It's like, they like focus on the fact if you don't have a fucking Lord icon on whatever character you're playing right now, that you're bad at it.
I'm like, so I need a Lord icon on fucking Loki.
Because I got blamed for like not playing Luna.
Because they're like, oh my god, have a lord icon on Luna and you don't play Luna?
And I'm like, what the fuck?
I can play any support.
Like, it doesn't necessarily mean, like, oh shit, I was not paying attention.
That's bad.
Our rocket ran up.
Okay, do we have... Oh, nice we do.
Can we get the... What are... No, we can't.
We couldn't.
Yeah, it's literally time today.
Yeah.
So that's why I wanted to fucking get... Did he just alted?
Yeah, I was like, what the fuck is he?
Oh, he still died.
That's awkward.
That's actually pretty awkward, actually.
I don't know how you still die.
Okay, I'm leaving.
Please, please, please, thank you.
Thank you.
It's hard dive.
They're just playing dive.
Oh yeah, they're just playing dive.
I have to reload.
I have to reload, please.
Please.
Please, I have to reload.
Please don't die.
I can't reload forever.
Oh my god, he jumped.
He jumped.
If he didn't jump, if he didn't jump, I would have frozen.
I'm not coping.
I swear to God.
If he didn't jump, I would have hit him.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have like looked at him, looked at blade instead.
It's not coping guys, it's not coping.
Oh now they're not doing that, okay.
Now they're just tanking it.
Don't worry, Wooply.
Oh my god.
That solo oven is insane.
Oh shit.
Here we go.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Or a little bit.
And then back up a little bit because I feel like he wants to...
Oh my god, it's just everything.
It's just there's so many things going on my screen.
Oh, goodbye.
Ah!
I'm alive.
I'm not gonna risk it.
Oh shit!
They don't know.
They don't know the crime I committed there.
They don't know, guys.
They don't know.
He doesn't know.
He's not gonna watch the recap.
He doesn't know what I did.
Yeah, see, you don't know.
You don't know either.
You don't know.
You don't know what I did because I didn't do anything wrong.
I didn't do anything wrong, guys.
Absolutely.
See, if you guys don't know, then I'm safe.
You guys didn't realize what I did because I didn't do anything wrong.
That's my logic.
Holy fuck.
What?
That should 100% hit, not gonna lie.
Okay, we're five.
See, we're so healthy!
We're so healthy!
Look at that!
He's 1 HP!
Look at us, girl!
What is he gonna do?
Punch him out of the air?
Like...
Get this guy out of here.
The current score is...
is this your third triple no why is this just my main account guys i just haven't played in a while chat i just i just haven't played in a while you'll need a top-notch team to win this one i just like watched that ironfish like punched in the air i'm like what the get down you're not meant to fly get down from here
Where's the Luna?
Because I did...
Okay guys, you gotta teach me how to convert it.
I literally have zero Luna Snowskins.
I have zero Luna Snowskins.
Because I just don't like any of the Luna Snowskins.
I just don't like any of the Luna...
The default one's the best one.
And even then, I don't like the color...
I just don't like the hair color for Luna.
In her summer.
In her bikini one.
I think that her bikini, uh, I don't sound like the hairstyle and the hair color of her bikini outfit.
My favorite anti-air weapon, mom.
I think, like, her outfit's good, but the hair color and the hairstyle, I don't like it.
People are too busy looking at something else.
They never notice the hair.
though I notice it it has to be a perfect 10 out of 10 skin for me to use it because like okay even though okay I would say Loki Loki has some of the best support skins um I would I feel like because like it's I was so hard to choose between like um his his summer skin or the president one one was is so good as well it's very hard to pick because i find loki has like the better skins overall but okay guys we have to oh my god of course he jumps a fucking course of course they jumped guys please someone shoot the supports maybe maybe that's a good idea
Oh my god, okay.
He was just punching me.
Like, what do I do?
What do you do when he...
Oh, that was a little too late, my buddy.
I mean, you can burst him.
Guys, I was gonna say it.
I don't know.
I don't like the...
I don't like the dress.
I personally don't like it.
Oh, wait.
They surrendered.
Yay!
I won by doing nothing at all.
Even though, you know, Loki has, it's crazy.
He basically is not wearing any, like, he's like 80% naked, but his...
The summer skin is still pretty good.
Okay, how do I convert my currency, guys?
You guys say I can convert it?
Alright, because look how much I have...
need to pay real money i have this i have this but i don't have this this is what you need for the luna bikini skin and like i have this much i have like 54 000 yeah that that is this is the bikini skin no no the luna bikini requires real money to because you need to buy the battle pass
It's just two inch big.
Oh, buddy.
It's not the size.
It's how you use it.
It's all.
Sorry.
Yes, it is.
It is above average.
Buy it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's pretty big.
If I super chat 50, you get Luna skin.
Yes, no.
I'm greedy.
Never my technique is what.
Zika thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I took it the green the art of the deal I am a business woman I you're a negotiation
take the money took it 50 oh my god there's threats now It's fucked!
60.
For the loon, baby koala.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
65.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
I'm setting my support for woobly nuns.
game the song five the extra five for the song the five is so greedy
supporting for the cause thank you for the super chat causing thank you Thank you, thank you.
I know what I am.
Oh, I thought he would go left, but he went right!
He's just a little healing.
Please we have two supports.
How do I not get like one heals?
Like, oh my god.
Poor don't worry, Groot.
Touch them with your two inches.
Very big deal with it.
Chris got this.
Strong together.
Okay, fine.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
Look at our group's name.
It's two inches big.
Money is sheep thong.
It's forever.
Mr. Broke and fine.
Thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, that poor guy.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Like...
Get out of here!
Did he get anybody?
He didn't.
It's okay.
It's just because it just wasn't...
If it was one inch longer, you would have got him, Groot.
I believe in you.
If it was just, you know, 0.1 inch longer, it would have gotten.
Dude, I believe...
Chill!
The slander!
It's fine, we have...
What are we doing in there?
Okay, we're...
We're doing it here.
so where everything will be did he just lock him in like oh he went into ice for him the moment I okay he has he has all he has all though okay I think I'm gonna avoid this iron fist I'm gonna avoid him for sure he is pretty bad yo blade I'm coming for heals mind you
Alright, we're fine.
If it's thong, it's not wrong.
Thank you.
We're in a super chat simple.
Oh my god!
They're all dead.
Unless...
Okay, it's just the perfect human that's dead.
It's okay, it's only the perfect human that died.
Wait, who has my...
snowflake oh he's dead oh my god fuck he's dead area Luna skin buns yami thank you was a super chat thank you thank you I'm gonna look into why I'm like lagging though like my gameplay is not lagging but but you know this is lagging a
Do you got anybody?
Oh, you did.
It's fine.
I got you guys.
Stand in a perfect line, please.
Yo!
Use the res!
Use it!
Oh, you could have used it earlier!
Why didn't you use it?
earlier okay let me check i don't know why i eliminated everything too maybe background if he is cat all right it's fine we have like four minutes it's fine oh wait i have c god i forgot the new team up i didn't think i had to ever use it though that to be fair i never felt threatened i didn't feel threatened at all i don't think i ever had to had to use something like that okay maybe this though there we go oh my god how did y'all oh that's how that's how they all died i was like what happened to them
oh crazy buddy crazy yeah fuck that guy in particular though okay we gotta kill okay there we go just do all the damage
too many tabs I don't have that many tabs though that's the thing let me check my
I'm a hundred CPU I have anti-alias on Is that bad?
Anti-alias.
Where do I put it?
Where is it?
This?
Where do I put it?
What do I put it as?
Oh, is that what I'm doing?
Turn it off?
How do I turn it off?
How do I turn anti-alias off?
How did I turn it up?
It just says Nibidia.
Scroll it.
There's no off!
Oh, off.
Enemies better beware.
Yeah.
I didn't realize you can scroll down.
You guys know that?
Guys, I did it.
I did it.
I did it everybody.
Oh my god.
Guys, why did nobody help me?
Oh my god, I'm okay now.
Look at that.
I'm actually okay now.
Wow, that's crazy.
Guys, I'm not lagging anymore.
Oh, I died though.
I...
After an hour, we figured it out.
Yeah, it's only me healing.
guys i'm not lagging anymore oh my god guys i'm not lagging oh my god i missed the jump whoops you don't know that though nobody saw that oh my um i wanted to i wasted my c there the race.
Guys, I did it.
I did it.
I hope he doesn't see.
I'm like, oh my god, he saw me from the...
Okay, that's me, folks.
I didn't realize.
Oh my god, why would you ever turn to your left?
I didn't...
I need to get raised!
That was too far.
Guys, I think after turning anti-aliased off, like, it made me worse as a player.
I don't know.
It might have made me worse as a player, guys.
It might have actually got me worse at the game.
I don't know how.
You know, you would have expected to improve.
Oh, a whiz.
Okay, if we...
Okay, I have to use this.
Because we're all here anyway
Okay, three two one Okay Oh my god Okay, he missed How many ults do they have?
Where is our odds?
Oh
my god, I'm just like
like thinking, have we had anything?
Maybe we're just both bad at defense.
Oh my god, where did he come from?
Where did this Emma come from?
Okay.
Who did all of these people come from?
Holy shit, the Luna died so fast.
I'm scared.
Hey guys, I'm not liking anymore.
Wait, what this anti-aliased does?
I've been playing FPS games for so long I don't know what any of my settings mean
Oh Doki That's a rage bait right Yeah yeah yeah that's I was just rage baiting guys But like pretending if I'm Like if I'm at Just explain to me as to the other dragoons Who might not know what What anti-alias means You know Explain it to the dragoons that don't know.
I was just rage baiting.
Yeah, I'm just...
Okay, so like, why do people turn that on, though?
Like, explain it to my dragoons that don't know.
Like, I know what, but, like...
I feel like some dragoons don't know.
Thanks.
Just for the...
Just for the dragoons who might not know.
I'm gonna back up a little bit.
I don't think I have to ult yet.
Oh no, you belong to her!
I made...
Okay.
That's fine.
Now know what?
Oh my god.
Oh thank god, okay.
I was like, don't look at me.
Okay, mine's gonna end before hers.
Oh my god, she's body blocking me!
Holy shit!
Okay, I don't know if you noticed, but I couldn't move because she was...
I think we were both body blocking each other, so she couldn't move either.
Our overasses were too big.
We were both body blocking each other there.
Or a thick booty.
I was trying to leave.
I told you.
The hair color is so ugly.
The hairstyle and I don't like the hairstyle and the hair color.
It's just a double combo.
If it was one, if it was just one of the things, then it's fine, but it's both of them that I'm not a fan of.
Holy shit!
Where did anyone get the license plate?
Like, I literally came out of the invisible wall!
What?
Okay, I might die if I look at them too long, so I'm gonna wait.
I am Groot.
Please go to the right side where majority of us is.
I would really appreciate that.
I hope he can kill him before he kills me.
Oh that's bad.
That's bad.
That's very bad.
are we okay okay we got this we got this we're a one-man army or two men we're okay three two one goodbye okay maybe we don't got this you know what it's fine they use so many others for that I just had no cover there with the portal.
Okay, that portal was a little not inspiring.
That portal...
That portal was a bit too crazy, you know?
Okay.
Oh my, the stall.
What the fuck?
We stalled for so long.
Holy shit.
Okay.
That's fine, we live.
I live.
Oh my god, someone save her.
Don't worry, we got this.
We can do this.
We can survive.
Don't worry, I got you.
You're not dying on my watch.
That's for your wife.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
I'm dead Oh my god, he just kept punching No, I'm not fan of any I'm not even fan of the the color variations of the bikinis.
I don't know.
I just don't like It just doesn't work for me.
I feel like Jesus Christ.
I'm so scared.
I'm dead.
I'm So dead.
Oh nice Okay, that's fine Don't worry our raccoons got this Down the healer No, we're not I'm here.
I'm here Come on guys Okay, all right, that's fine.
I'll just get punched into healing I guess Okay, four three
one it's fine it's not fine because he's coming to me now oh my god are you fucking kidding me that's so unlucky that's why this is my health back oh my God, he destroyed it so fast.
No.
There's nothing I could do.
There was nothing I could do.
Yo, there's actually no way.
Spider-Man, can you please let me DPS, bro?
Just please, please.
I was maybe, maybe, um, hot guy and Spider-Man was not it.
Just a...
He's like, no, it's not me.
The other guy's like, I'm not the problem.
It's the support's fault for not healing me.
I'm not the problem.
That's unlucky.
28-17 is crazy.
Please don't sell this.
Hope it wasn't hindering too much that I was lagging.
My skin suit was lagging, guys.
I hope it wasn't hindering the stream too much, guys.
Okay, don't worry, it's fine.
That's good.
We should know.
Oh, Renkis says GM too.
I might stop when I get to Celeste deal, maybe.
I don't know.
I don't know how I feel.
I like how I feel.
I like how many always tried to throw snowballs with me though.
I like how Booply is using the heal function so our Ironman just gets just a little extra heals.
You know?
Just that one little extra heals.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Someone kill this door!
Someone!
Don't break his shins!
Wait, I hear like, rocket, not rocket thing.
Where's our item?
I need to, like, save him.
Oh my god!
This is real firepower!
Oh my god, I have to reload.
I don't have I actually I don't have a so that See guys, it's not the Iron Man's fault.
It was the support
You guys need to let me keep you guys you need to let me keep you doing fine.
All right
Holy shit Like the moon my shine in darkness.
Yeah, you're gonna make fun of me of that sorry i'm just sick of failing and losing these long ass free games bro he's like bro what the be positive that's not a grand mastery mentality you weren't positive five seconds ago when you were mocking my voice so don't be oh oh wait wait i'm not mocking your voice gentlemen Gentlemen,
do I have to show you my titties?
Will that make you smile?
Okay, I'm whipping my skirt.
Oh, please, please, please, please.
See, that's all it took.
Was a big booty, Latina, showing off her curves?
I can see the cake right now.
I can literally see it.
Yes, I want to.
If we sell this, I'm finding all your addresses.
Now listen.
What the fuck is this?
If we lose this, I'm finding all your addresses.
I'm...
Oh, Joe!
My big booty Latina's gonna find where I live!
What do I do?
I have the real questions.
What can those two inches do?
What do you mean?
I mean nothing.
They get dubs, that's what it does.
Oh, that's a good one.
Oh, I'm steamy dubs.
Oh, I'm steamy.
Damn, this is what my rival rivals does to a person.
This is why we keep voice chat on.
Guys, this is exactly why.
They won.
This is exactly why.
What the hell?
It's called MyVarivals.
You hear that?
Two inches go crazy, guys.
From Mr. Is 2-inch big himself.
It does a lot to a person.
It does.
It really does.
Wait.
His history?
Okay.
That means I should absolutely check his history.
This guy?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, I don't think he's okay.
I don't think he was okay.
I'm seeing it like that.
Papa smear thank you for the super chat thank you thank you my oh she's the best at reading can I play Loki now Loki I literally need like like I think 10 more games on Loki uh and then I can have I can have the lord icon that's all I need we do play one have a ball player I'm gonna get Let me play loop low-key.
I got a BP player, by the way.
You won above all players.
No way we lose these, right?
Who's the other one?
I don't know how to even select all three, though.
But you didn't know it was me.
Do you guys use trackers?
Is this how you're seeing this?
Oh, you're peak, yeah.
I mean, MPP, but...
Why are you using trackers, man?
I don't want to go against BP.
Wait, he uses trackers?
they use third party trackers to figure out like um like even you hide your stuff the third party trackers can see your information my go south lock but ptock's much more is there yeah there's like third party trackers so they know who to ban so they look at i look is easier to do third party trackers make it so that you can know who to ban because it shows like who you're like it shows like what their mains are and everything no yeah that was like a pure so they could target bad going through my veins when you said that have you not like yeah but you can't ban it there's no way to actually ban it no like he would kill both supports in less than a second yeah i would assume that yeah what was your what was your backline tell me uh i think we were a low-key cloak That's why you're fucking dying.
You're going Loki cloaking against BP.
Why are you playing Loki cloaking against BP?
Loki's anti-dive?
No!
At least no!
He gets two-shotted!
One of the best anti-dive supports.
I think I might know more.
I think I might know a little bit more about what's better against BP.
I'm against a BP.
I'm probably going Loki or cloak or... I mean, not... I would go invis, but I don't like it.
No, go Luna Sue, and it's... You're done.
You're just OP.
You press right click, you sit next to the shield, boom, you're done.
Oh, yeah, but yo, there's the immortality fields that are so cool.
And they make it so, and then guess what happens when they're after it, right?
He comes back in, two shots are Loki, boom, you're done.
Nah.
He just went, he just went, nah.
After like all the explanation, he's just like, nah, he's rage baiting.
He doesn't actually do the heal.
It's not his fault.
He's actually rage baiting.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
He actually just walked into that.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, my thing is...
My thing already got deleted.
That's crazy.
Maybe I shouldn't do this.
What the fuck?
He's so far away.
You're free.
Actually free.
Okay, that's fine.
Go look back!
It's okay!
I don't matter.
Why are we going Punisher?
Oh, I got that.
No.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I need to stop talking.
He's just like, no!
No!
It's just straight up That's fine I've really fucking takes forever to build a lot Just come over come over here.
Oh shit.
I didn't even get it I'm scared I don't even have luck Not building all in time.
Yeah, I'm not building it in time actually a curse I don't have my I don't have my ult in time okay
okay I'm softening off Loki I'm not build my my tanks died too fast for me to build all right also like Loki's oh my god he dies too fast for me to build it
Okay, maybe I could do something.
Maybe...
There you go.
There was nothing I could do.
Alright, I have to play Luna.
I have to play... Our...
Our thing is not...
Our thing just really wants to die.
He's feeding like a fucking crazy easy Okay, I am severely confused about this team comp.
So we had Thor thing moon night and now you're on cloak I mean, I feel like heals are a big issue there I wasn't getting healed in front of both heals and our tanks are just not No, just have no front line Thor is useless and thing doesn't have a good second tank to be able to be enabled.
Why?
Not get heals.
I was healing you.
I'm just getting dittled.
No, no, the heals are fine.
We just have no further.
What is it?
It's time.
Useless ass Thor, number one.
And then you can't do anything because he doesn't have like a mag or anything else.
Don't worry.
If we're going triple support, it's time.
Well, in that case, it's time.
This is the only reason to go triple support.
There's no reason to go do that.
to do this.
Alright.
It's time!
I haven't played Ultron in a very long time!
But it's time!
It's time!
I haven't played this character in so long, but it's time!
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
I hope they're...
To be fair, I needed to...
Please.
Thank you.
All right, there you go.
You have to do the stupid diamond thing when you're flying.
But it's time!
Oh, he fell down.
Whoops, I should not...
That's because I floated down.
I wasn't paying it.
I didn't realize he was going to do that.
Where the fuck are...
Where are people fighting?
I'm so confused.
I'm trying.
There we go.
I'm doing it.
Oh, okay.
That fucking sucks.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's okay, we have this.
There we go.
It's not fine now.
He's not gonna throw it up, right?
He's not.
Okay, he didn't throw it up.
Thank God.
There you go.
I had it on her.
There was nothing I could do.
Like, there was nothing I could do.
I gave all my resources.
That's fine.
We got it at 85.
That's something, right?
Oh yeah, no.
I need to remember the fear.
It's been so long, I forgot to fear.
It's been...
It's been so long, I forgot what fear was like.
Don't worry, luckily I remember.
Okay.
Get the atom?
Yep.
Oh my god.
Oh my really?
Oh my god, how did everybody die?
Oh my god.
I don't know how my supports...
I don't know how... I thought they were together.
I don't know, both were some other two supports died.
They should be like babysitting each other, but they weren't.
I was like, guys, guys, we're support players.
We gotta babysit each other, guys.
We gotta keep each other healthy.
It is a team effort.
We had...
Oh no, not born again.
Wait, where is it?
Oh my god, it's too all right.
That's where it was.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm fearing, but it's okay.
Because it's okay.
Uh, get near me.
Get near me.
We don't need us.
We don't need it.
Please kill him.
Uh, get...
Okay, we...
Okay!
Why?
Okay.
We.
Oh, why did he?
Why?
That's fine.
Okay.
You know what?
It's fine.
We could have saved that.
I...
But we're sad.
Like, there was...
There was...
literally they didn't even came in we could have saved that for when they came in i was like why are you doing that
i just fly he need yeah he needs clips i was just like bro like just wait literally wait five seconds it would have been fine that's gm you move with such stealth might stop i'm just i'm gonna Celestio, because then matches, matches improve, because a lot of the,
a lot of good players are in Celestia at the moment.
I mean, eternity ends Celestio, but you know.
I think, like, Diamond 1 to Celestio in just two days, I think that's a good progress.
I think that's a good progress.
I haven't played, does it, is it noticeable?
I haven't played Ultra in a while?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I, no, I usually never I am the one that plays Ultron.
Usually I'm not the one that has the honor of playing Ultron.
Because everyone else...
Everyone else gets to play Ultron.
Because all the other DPS players play Ultron.
You know?
Oh, fuck it.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, that's unlucky.
That's unlucky.
Hey, they're linked.
Oh, are you serious?
I even... that's unlucky too.
That's not fair.
Focus on him.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Yes, get on point guys.
Oh, never mind Don't worry Are you serious?
Oh my
Jesus Christ I could control us I can't be there forever
Guys, I've been alive for so long.
I built another all I built another all this That's how long I've been alive for.
I've been alive for so long.
I...
The fact that I got another ult out of all that.
That was crazy.
That's how long I was alive for.
Oh, like, I'll go at him after I will.
Oh, my God.
That's huge.
That's actually huge.
Oh, at least he didn't get slammed.
That's good.
Focus on the mad, sis!
Nice.
Okay, I don't know about that though, but that's fine.
Oh, that's unlucky.
This is gonna be the stall of the fucking century.
To who?
Me?
He like... Okay.
Okay.
It was to me.
Nice.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Actual stall.
They stall for so long.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I have to actually shoot my gun.
Wait, that's huge, that's huge.
Oh, I'm fucking trying to keep you up, buddy.
Please.
Oh!
How mighty also I have to build!
Holy shit!
How many heals?
So many heals.
It is actually crazy how many heals I was doing.
Bitch.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I don't know.
Do I play?
I feel like I play Adam.
I'm gonna play Adam.
Where are I, Luna?
I think, I think it's the play.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, that's very unlucky.
That's very unlucky.
Our support's ran in.
Our support's ran in to the point of...
I did this for my Luna.
I'm gonna grab one, right?
That's so unlucky.
I use both snaps.
No, that's bad.
Oh,
I don't have.
I hope he lives.
It's fine.
Why me?
Why am I the one getting snowflake?
I'm literally...
I don't know why.
I don't know
why.
It's me.
It's the only one I could do.
Yeah, this is clearly...
I can't do anything else.
There's nothing else I could do.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was the clone.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
We win?
I hate you, Thor.
I hate you.
We made this game 10 times harder now to be.
I literally am clenching my ass because of how close these games are.
It's not supposed to be this hard.
Your character fucking sucks.
You can play something else.
You're not special.
You're literally not special at all.
You're not out.
Whoa.
XDD.
Bro, did that.
I got 17k damage.
more damage than the ultron bro this guy has been on ultron the entire game how do i have more damage than you i was on low key for one man
than you i literally was playing i swapped out ultron like later
he's got more kills yeah he got fucking tickle damage Like, that's your luck.
He asks us, oh, that, oh, my God, that's not my profile, by the way.
Mine's not like that.
Mine's a lot better looking, guys.
Like, mine's a lot.
Mine's look a lot better.
Don't worry.
Oh, I think, I think Wooply is avoiding people.
uh
um but yeah to be fair we did it that was okay i yeah that no we had to avoid people there no i'm gonna avoid i mean i don't think i think i our our thing had really good alts but like i don't know the rest of my team were pretty special
Oh, please sounded very happy.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, where's my...
Where's my 65?
65.
We're gonna...
One last...
One last shake for the...
ride oh wait guys we're doing this
like Can I put this as a picture?
Thank you for the super magenta soup.
Thank you.
All right, it's time.
All right, where's the thing?
Oh, let me grab my...
Okay.
Thing.
where is it why is she stalling I was enjoying my show you can't just stop the show guys I was enjoying my show oh my gosh you don't just stop somebody while they're mid performing guys you don't just do that it's fucked up alright 990 okay that's what how much is that that's like that's $10 okay I'm adding my funds adding exactly that's like $15 Canadian dollars.
Yeah, but he doesn't have the right emotes.
That's the thing.
Yeah, sure.
He got the thon.
But where's my twerk?
The twerk should be applied to every character.
All the male characters, though.
The women should have the throwing money and the male characters should have the twerking.
Okay.
There you go.
back how far is the luna one how many at the purchase oh my god the real money okay we're we're waiting until we're gonna play it we're gonna wait we haven't we can't afford it yet it's apparently the max battle pass to get luna snow all right but okay do i have any good emotes though on thing where is he where is is is emotes emotes i mean you could sit on a chair I guess.
Okay, let me see.
Okay.
Oh, that one.
The monkey one.
Okay, we'll make him sit on the chair, I guess.
Well,
okay.
Change.
Oh, we'll just make him sit on the chair.
There we go.
Not the chair.
share because it let you know it's there's all right start the queue yeah the thought nice here's the thought here you go i mean like when he sits down you can sort of like the rock
read the what does the book say the other thing oh it says the other thing there you go why does he it's a rock he's made of rocks okay i'm just thinking like can you just put pebbles down there like you know
what if you just put pebbles down there to pack it you know he's a rock
Don't keep, please.
He's a rock.
That's all I'll say.
I'm just sad he has no ass.
You know?
Like, it's so flat.
Look at this.
Like, I guess, like, I guess he doesn't need it, but still.
He should.
Why does it have to be so blank?
Because then it'd be weird if it's...
like if it was like soft because then like you know people will be like wait why he'll be like wait a minute aren't you made of rock that's why you don't use normal padding you use like you use pebbles or rocks or something
I said you enough for the whole thing
no he said he said I I remember hearing the thing.
Get the thing song.
That was not a scam.
The art of the deal.
Now look.
I put on the song.
For the thing.
Sorry, I realized that sounded weird off contest.
So I have to say for the thing.
For the thing.
The thing put on the sign!
For the thing!
What map is this?
Oh, we're defending.
Okay.
Tingus pingus.
Why the fuck?
Why are everybody's names so funny today?
Everybody has such creative names.
Okay, guys.
How desperate are you for the Luna skin?
Show me, show me, like, a fight for it.
I want to see the dedication.
How desperate.
Not really.
Okay, remember this, guys, we don't get the Luna skin because of fluffy dolphin.
All because of this one person.
Uh...
The one person that I decided speaks for all of you.
I figured, because he clearly speaks for all of you, right?
Why?
Or...
Okay, I...
I was gonna sit.
Um, please!
Please!
Baby!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I, there's no way I should play low key with a rocket.
It's like, dumb.
Wait.
Fluffy, thank you for the secret.
Oh, you regret that?
Fluffy's like, wait a minute.
I was joking, guys.
It was just a he-he-he-he guy.
I was joking, please.
Okay.
I'll do this just in case.
I'm worried.
I want to do double rise too.
There you go.
I had to because I already used my up.
Yeah.
I am ready to put on a show.
Judge, jury, executioner!
Okay, um, he's dead.
There's...
Yeah, I need a swap.
There's nothing.
Loki is not the play here.
Because I have Rocket.
Like, how the fuck am I gonna do?
Like, Rocket is such a weird-ass copy.
Wait, actually, I should play Loki for the clones here.
I am accused of loving chaos.
Is this true?
I am barely harmed.
What a slide guard you are.
There you go.
I had to, like, thank god Ashley played the key here.
That actually was clutch.
That was Ashley so clutch.
Oh my, free fun!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Loki is so stressful sometimes.
All right.
He belongs to her.
Where's Rocket?
Oh my god.
Live!
Oh, I saved them!
I'm a hero!
Oh, I'm a hero!
I'm actually a hero.
hero i'm actually a hero i don't know what to do about that though i'm like i don't okay um i don't know i'll use it for myself though i like i shouldn't have spammed that shift okay i can't do anything about that i can't do it I couldn't do anything about that though.
I don't know if we could touch.
All right.
Now I play Luna.
I spammed shift so I couldn't do anything.
We're switching.
I don't even know who he's telling him to switch for.
It's just harder to play Loki with the rocket alt as the copy.
It's better if it's like Luna or the coffee.
I don't think magic is working, though, to be fair.
Yeah!
Not yet.
Where's my rocket?
Where's my...
Did my...
Oh!
He's so stupid.
He's...
Oh my god, he's so stupid.
We just needed a stack.
If we...
Oh my god.
This is the rocket player that doesn't try.
their other support.
Because, like, you're supposed to stack where your other support and then heal each other.
We had to heal each other through it.
Instead, he just left me to die.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
Like, is he dumb?
Yeah, he lived.
But we could have three people living.
Like, three of us could have lived.
That's why I was like, oh my god, he's so stupid.
I'm not gonna use anything yet.
We don't have to.
Yeah, I do.
I have to...
Oh my gosh, he's so neat.
Nice.
Or he's gonna have Punisher Alt, though.
I know this has Punisher Alt.
He's gonna have...
We have Moon Knight Magic as our fucking DPS lineup.
What?
That's fine.
We win this fight, though.
Oh, I thought the shield was going to get off soon here.
It's okay.
Forgive Fluffy of their sins.
They went led astray.
Fluffy, is that true?
Do we forgive?
Are we supposed to forgive you, Fluffy?
Is this true?
Real magic.
I've not seen magic players in so long.
Let's be fair.
I think they might TP.
unless they oh no they they cancel TP because there was supposed to be a TP here nope there is I think I'm dead
how did two people die like why did we why did we push up we knew they had TP why did we push up oh my god what a throw I don't understand.
It was so obvious, too.
It wasn't like there was not gonna be a TP.
Okay, this is a very fucking weird ass.
Okay, yes, I'm pretty sure he's getting close to us.
I'm gonna be careful here.
Oh my god.
The raccoon was next to me.
I am ready to...
Oh, my God.
If the raccoon didn't fucking stand next to me, it would have been fine.
He literally stood next to me, so I couldn't do anything.
Oh, my God.
Did he shoot him?
Because I shot him.
I felt like it took him so long to die.
Did he shoot him?
Oh, my God.
shoot the iron man like i swear to god if he shot him we would have both lived
i mean it's smart we literally
okay this is fine rocket did in fact i'm gonna watch the replay i need to know if he shot him then like i'd be like okay it's fine it's it's it's not fine but it's fine.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That was huge.
Our Mac knows how to fucking pay.
Our Mac knows.
He knows.
He actually knows.
He knows how to game.
Okay, one last fight.
We have a raccoon.
That's right.
I'll keep slandering him.
He doesn't deserve any rights because he's an animal.
He's not even a real raccoon anyway.
I don't know if he'll live.
Oh, he doesn't even touch.
He's an abomination!
Not even a real raccoon!
He's a genetic freak!
That's right, I said it.
He was grown in a lab!
He was grown and I fucking love!
Yeah!
That's messed up.
He ain't right, that one.
That one ain't right.
I've seen this.
This is a classic.
This is a new stream.
I cut it in a real one.
Chikada, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I cried in the third movie.
How could you?
And I cheered.
Guys, I swear to God, I'm not a sociopath.
I swear to God, it's just, I don't know, it's just raccoons, man.
Not even a real fucking raccoon.
That's the worst part.
He's not even a real fucking raccoon.
He was growing in the goddamn lab.
all the guardians movies that one ain't right
like i don't know who would have none of them are flankers so i'm just like who the fuck do i give my snowflake to i guess i'll just i'll give it to like our bucky for now
don't insult this trash band it's not insulting if it's true
jesus holy shit we already have all that's actually crazy that we already got all up there like i'm at 50 like how are we charging her all that oh i guess we were all grouped up there too that's actually crazy we just What happened?
Okay, um, LOS.
Gomez did not LOS.
There you go.
That's not on me.
That was a lack of LOS right there.
Okay, he is getting heavily pocketed.
Please, please, please, please.
There you go.
We got it just in time.
Thanks so much.
I am ready to put on a show.
Jesus.
Mutant gun.
Aw, I even damaged the truce in it too.
Okay, please, please.
Oh, the oh, no!
I don't know.
I feel it.
For survivability, I might actually have to play low key.
have I'll do it just for survivability I think like oh yeah no our DPS yeah no our DPS sucks one of them is definitely not performing I'll say that one of us is one of our DPS is not doing so well for sure
There we go.
Oh, I was gonna say, how did he die?
I was so confused.
I was like, wait, he's dead?
Please.
Please live so I can...
Please live.
I have to reload.
That's good.
That's not good.
Yay!
Phoenix!
Nice.
Alright.
We're good.
Everything is okay.
I need to check how many more playtime I need for the Lloyd icon.
Yay!
I'm Phoenix!
Re-racunos, by the way.
Yeah, and I still have more assist, bitch.
Jesus, friend.
Just in case.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
We're doing it.
You are just...
I have many faces.
Where's that?
Where?
Oh!
I was like, where is it?
I hear you are nothing.
I'm like, where's the up?
Where is the up?
Where did the up go?
I was so confused.
True.
Yeah, I was like, I heard it.
Where is it?
I am ready to put on a show.
So many of us.
This is a non-stop fight.
Okay, that's not my fault.
I literally am doing my best I could.
There we go.
Just stand there for a sec.
And then...
And then we wait.
Okay, I'm a little scared top-peaked, though.
Like, I don't feel safe, guys.
Oh, nice.
Fear.
I actually, I don't feel safe.
Oh, I'm feeling- I'm safe now.
Yay!
I feel safe now.
Oh, my god.
It's fine.
You can't touch.
I'm alright.
Oh, shit.
I should have healed.
Alright.
Where did she go?
I was like, bro, she disappeared.
Where did my Phoenix go?
I got confused.
Okay, I hope our rock yields first.
And then I'll- After.
I have to use that.
What the fuck?
My lamp disappeared so fast.
I am Phoenix!
Yay!
Don't let anything stay in your way.
Final score.
We did it!
Still more assist.
You might have more healing.
Assist matters more.
Because that means I help get kills.
That's what it means, guys.
doesn't matter it was me yay gm1 yeah i did it i did it guys 50 that's actual sad the enemy luna had 56k healing and i'd i'd be so depressed i i'm at healing 56k and i'm also i'm avoiding this I'm avoiding it.
Don't talk to me.
That guy was not inspirational at all.
That guy was... Oh, yeah.
I have to watch the replay.
I need to know.
Did you shoot at the Iron Man?
Who added me?
What the fuck?
I don't know who you guys are.
Alright.
Okay, I need to see.
I need to know.
Did they shoot?
I'll buy the Luna skin after.
This is more important.
right now.
I need a note.
Did you shoot?
Okay, where did he get?
Okay, this is Team B claim the checkpoint.
Okay, it was right here.
Alright.
Okay, he shot.
Okay, okay.
He shot.
Alright.
All is forgiven.
Okay.
I take back everything I said.
about this particular raccoon player.
Just this one, though.
Just this raccoon player.
I take everything back.
Alright.
How much is this?
Purchase level?
How much is the max?
2,400?
How much is that?
Bro, what?
Okay, I have to buy this and this.
It's $25.
I mean, I got fine.
Fine.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Okay.
But if I level up two more times, if I level up two more times, it's just $2,000.
Guys, it's just $2,000 if I level up two more times.
So I'll buy this for now, so I don't have to spend another $5.
I don't know.
guys i just need two i just need to level up two more times guys i just and then so that i can only spend i don't have to spend 25 i can spend 20.
do you guys know how much it's 30 canadian 20 you how bad is our currency 20 american dollars is 30 canadian now how when did our currency like
currency what happened what a very bad monopoly
money how did he get more monopoly that's normal ain't it he gets and that yeah it always has been oh my god i didn't realize that that it got this bad okay we're gonna level up we just need to level up twice we just okay just two more levels and then i'll i can purchase it i bought see look see i have enough for it but if i level up twice then it's just 30 canadians i can't believe the scam anyway like here's 20 zekra thank you for the super chat thank you thank you see this is why i this is why um i leveled up two times and then i save five dollars
not not a scam
Simple, business, it's just business.
It's not a scam.
I bought the currency.
I bought it.
Guys.
I bought it, guys.
Look, see?
I have the...
I have...
Look, see?
I have it.
I have the currency, guys.
I have.
It's right there.
I just.
I just need.
Okay.
After this game.
I'll buy it.
Okay.
After this game.
I'll buy it.
Because I think after this game.
Guys, after this game.
I'll get the level.
I'll get the level up.
It'll have be the level up, guys.
It'll be the level up, chat.
After this game.
where you can level it up oh yeah i want to check the low key proficiency oh my god it's gonna take me fucking forever all right i still it's gonna take i'm not close at all yes i'm not i feel like i feel like i need like i need like um play this for like maybe one more day to actually get the
healing require i mean i'm almost there but it's like a long way to go
um it's like 100 yeah this is a long way to go i'm not even halfway bro loki's fucking requirements are so dumb what the i feel like loki is harder to build up because like this is easy to get this is easy like freeze 20 yeah this is easy like 20 enemies freeze 20 enemies and Loki is like create a hundred and eighty illusions like what is that okay this is fine like what the fuck a hundred and eighty it's easy to freeze 20 people then fucking create a hundred and eighty illusions I I don't even think you can get like like what yeah just send them out yeah Yeah,
that's insane.
Look, I got Cloak and Dagger one.
What is it?
Where's Cloak and Dagger?
Where is she?
There she is.
This is easy.
Because, like, 80 KOs and Assist, you get that, you get this.
You get a lot of this from just her ult, like, Assist.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Keep on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have five dollars!
All right.
I am Loki, god of mischief, and the king of discard.
God damn it, I guess it's not.
I don't want a copy raccoon!
Let me- I was gonna- I almost banned Torch.
I don't know.
I don't fucking know, Scylla.
Wolf?
We don't even...
I don't guess.
Hmm.
That's fine.
Okay.
I mean, they ban Torch.
I guess I'll ban Seidog.
I don't know.
Because Wooply can play Seidog.
Phoenix?
Fine.
Phoenix is actually pretty bad in higher yellow.
But like, in this yellow nobody bans Phoenix for some reason.
Never leave Luna jail.
This is...
Wait, is this...
I think this is a good Loki map, too, right?
I'll remember.
Of course his name is the Raccoon Player's Buck Woofer.
Of course it is.
What?
Which one is bad to deal with?
Or bad as a character?
Raccoon?
Yeah, no.
Raccoon's...
Ugh, fine.
They're like, go back to Luna.
I'm like, but I don't wanna.
I don't wanna.
I want my Loki Lloyd.
Wha.
Oh yeah, by the way, the new...
I main DPS, but when I...
Why would a DPS main play Rocket?
Out of all the support characters, why would you, if you're a DPS player, like, wouldn't you want to play a character that's more required aim?
Um, like, that doesn't make sense.
Why would you play the character that requires the least amount of aim?
You don't even pew pew gun!
You don't, you don't need, there's no positioning too.
You're literally, like, I don't know, this doesn't make sense.
Like, I understand if you're like, oh my god, he's dead.
Oh, it's dive.
It's dive.
Look at that.
Look at that sick-ass freeze I did, though.
That...
Yeah, there's a fucking Iron Fist that's ready to fuck me up.
Right here.
I knew it.
i knew it he was ready i told you he was ready to me up and i was right i was so right there was no way to live here okay i might have to go invis i can too yeah i need to go invis or i'm just gonna get died i i made it to 50 so changing my character wouldn't make a difference now
for my freeze is too bad uh too big okay
i i gave so many shields that's not on me that's not on me that's not on me
i did everything i could
i don't waste my shields too much jesus christ good i don't know man
Oh my god.
Jesus, guys!
You're taking so much damage.
Whoops.
Oh my god, we're fucked!
We're so dead.
Okay, I don't know, guys.
I think this is GG's.
I'm not...
Yeah, our rocket...
Oh my...
Our rocket died so fast.
That's...
That's like, sad.
Guys, I don't think we're winning this.
I think we're actually gonna get full health.
Guys!
This seems like a...
Wait, why?
Why?
There's no...
Holy shit!
I'm so confused.
Why are we all to that?
Yeah, I mean, like, what do I do?
Yeah, this...
This might be...
This might be GG.
This might be a little bit GG, guys.
Just a little bit.
Oh, hey, look.
He got off a rocket.
Yeah.
No more delays.
Why are we TPing with 30 seconds left?
That's true.
Who called for Puerda?
Oh, Buckwoofer.
Yeah, I also wonder...
Yeah, also, yeah, I'm not gonna lie, this TP's...
Like, what is this TP?
Oh my god!
Like, what?
Let's just go main every time.
Like, I'm dead in this.
Yeah, I was gonna say, there's no way I'm bursted.
Yeah, that...
That was a very interesting TP.
That...
Yeah, not only like, why did we TP so early, but like...
Yeah, no, I don't think this...
I think this game was not it.
Why wouldn't it be on the portal?
Wait, why did he...
Yeah, like, you don't TP high ground anymore.
You just walk on point with TP.
You just walk on point.
There's no reason to TP on.
Alright, let's do it.
The Sue Luna thing that Wooply kept yelling about.
Being the perfect dive counter.
Yeah, and we're leaving him on...
I think we're...
We have to avoid the...
Iron Man because we're leaving him TPS
Would have what if I got the skin It'd be
Check my win rate Rocket with Rocket Check my win rate with Rocket This season and last season What do you mean this season you're still here on rocket You're still in GM on rocket.
It took me one day to get out of that like to get to GM one like it took me one day Like you're still here.
You're Thanks so much
What the fuck is I'm literally like Four games away from Celestial In the one day Like You're still a GM Like
The fact that he was like The fact that he was like Checked my win rate on Rocket I'm like Why are you still here then?
You have such an insane win rate!
He's still here!
Oh my god.
True solo queue is miserable.
Okay, let's chill this guy.
There we go.
Come back.
Come fucking back.
Right now.
Get your ass here.
newcomers the way of the raccoon putting in that fucking work baby putting in that
work okay it's like that what was it poopy scoopy poopy scoopy looking 800
if you are watching whooply-doo but you all first if you're watching you all first on end is okay okay
help him help him help him get us get his kill there we go here we go wait now we have oh i'm on a useful support and then we were winning though whoa whoa all right not not oh
It's fine, we have...
Bro,
brother, I'm playing a useful support and I'm healing my team.
You can't do it because your ego is too large to want to play an actual support so you want to play Rocket instead.
Oh, we lost both.
I'm scared.
Okay.
okay i don't feel okay oh we're not oh my god we're not okay we are not okay oh my god we are we're not okay we're i am gonna be that guy but the fact that you know the thing that's projecting is you like what the fuck your decisions are it shows what person you are
don't think we were okay in the end.
I don't think we were okay in the end.
Five.
Oh yeah, he was on Rocket.
That's what I'm saying.
He's a Bucky player.
Why the fuck would you play Rocket?
Bucky requires like so much like positioning and aim.
Why are you a Rocket player?
All right, maybe it is time for retail there.
Okay, did I level up though my battle pass?
Guys, I just need one more level.
Okay, okay.
Let's see.
There you go.
Guys, look.
I have four.
Oh, I have this.
I have this poster in real life.
They gave it to me.
Do you remember?
Please.
Guys, but I got frozen flow.
Guys, look, I just need one level.
Look at that, guys.
Just one.
Look, see?
I had this, though.
It's almost like the Luna skin.
See?
Look at that.
It's almost...
I don't like the hair color.
I just...
If it could have been any other hair color, I would have been fine with the hairstyle if the hair color was different.
I don't even like the recolors for this, too.
Guys, it's fine.
I can make it.
that's like what two to three more games that's okay the reason why is this
guys oh my god i'm literally missing 10 okay oh my god it's one dollar okay guys it's one dollar i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick of your back
while she's gone you guys need to spam the angry dragoon and make her buy the yellow recolor okay that's what you guys need to do
which hero do you think you want to be today
i love y'all not you guys in game but the people in somewhere else talking to my voices
hey guys i'm back
Mandy Alan thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right all right I'll buy I'll buy it I'll buy it I'll buy it after this game buy the yellow wait Does the recolor?
Does the recolor require yellow currency or blue currency?
Guys, this is important.
Pick your hero.
Is it yellow currency or...
I can't do it now!
I can't!
The new... God damn it!
Oh, I have enough?
Okay, that's all that matters.
I have enough.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
If only I had...
You know...
He could have stopped Q.
It's not my fault.
That's all I'm saying.
He could have waited for me to buy it.
That's not him.
That's Wupply's fault.
He didn't stop Q.
So it's not my fault.
Yeah, it's Wupply's fault.
Look at him.
Denying the people what they want.
right there i was gonna buy it when i came back from the bathroom he did he was the one that denied the people what you all wanted you wanted the skin i was gonna buy it the moment i came back from the
bathroom i had to pee i've been playing rivals for almost three hours i gotta pee i drank a lot of
exactly could you she lied as easy i'd never lie today
why the did the cloak use the fucking oh there you go i saved your life i'm a hero
okay it's fine i'm still a hero
It's fine.
I'm still the hero.
Today, you say.
Yes, today I would never die.
There's a Spider-Man?
Bro, what?
I swear I never even saw.
Oh my god, they're full dab.
Look at this comp.
This comp is disgusting.
Their actual full dab.
This comp fucking sucks.
For a support.
Like, holy shit.
I have to like be so careful too I have to babysit my I need a babysit everybody there you go there we go we're alive me and you Loki we're alive Luna takes so long to build heals now what the What is this?
What was this?
Okay, I need to know what the plan was, though, from that guy.
Like, I need to, like, what was his plan?
Actually.
Oh, no.
He copied the wrong person.
I swear.
old you know he tried wait what he fell down how did oh spider-man spider-man i'm coming back i'm coming back live oh it's okay it's venom he'll live that's venom he'll he'll fucking live don't worry don't worry it'll be a lot i believe i don't think we have to use anything actually keep fighting until we have a winner okay how far away
it's okay my team's got this a team it could have been anyone oh it's okay didn't have the alt let's go you we will remember this uh mr mud fluffing kids they give the super chat thank you thank you laughing for you today huh thank you for the super chat thing it resets every 24 hours
i get like one and it's like it's like a little it's like it's not like a lie it's like omitting information that's different it's like a little surprise Yay!
He killed me so I didn't have to waste my luck.
Waste my luck.
No, no, no, no, no.
Your set's every 24 hours.
One!
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Yay!
Hello everybody.
Hello everyone.
I think I...
No, he's fine.
Bro, we're just harassing this one venom.
And he lives?
Like, I literally saw all of us just shoot the venom.
Wait, why?
Not even gonna...
Oh wait.
was oh my god don't worry i got oh my god i don't my god i sort of oh my god just pretend that when he said two damage i did do the damage okay i don't think we needed that though he doesn't know he thinks it's so hard to see if i did damage or not i definitely did Lafayette,
thank you, a super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah.
I watched that new boss baby.
Oh, I almost let him die.
I watched that new boss baby movie, the back in...
Okay, it's not new.
It came out, like, years ago.
But, like...
But, like, that new boss...
The last boss baby movie is...
Oh, my God.
I...
I trolled.
Maybe that's karma for talking about boss baby.
But, like, it's actually cool.
crazy because like the dad goes reverse back to a child and then he like hangs out with his daughter and he's like trying to teach her how to like be brave oh my god that's three be brave and singing so that it's crazy because i i saved your life it's crazy because he's like in her room and it like they frame it as if like his daughter has like like it was like back to the future as like they okay you actually you actually killed him oh my god you actually killed that man holy shit that guy that guy died because of oh
you guys didn't see what happened okay but yeah they framed it as like because like the parents like the mom and the grandmothers were taking pictures and they're like oh you're so cute and then and then I'm just thinking like why like this is so fucking weird this is so like why did you like because he's like don't worry like I'm so proud of like shit like that to like my daughter when he's like her like he got reverted to her age
it's such a weird movie
no it's because it's like okay i was trying to find a clip and like he goes to her room and be like come on i'll teach you how to sing and it's like it's so weird i was like watching it i was like why why is it framed like why are you in her room yeah like you know you're her dad but she if she gets a crush on you like it's so weird that that that because like he like sits next to her and like encourages her as like her classmate and everything but it's so weird it's so fucking weird it's like the back to the future shit with marty mcfly and his mom but in animation
it's we should watch the last boss baby movie together guys so i can like Show you guys how fucking weird that is.
Like, so you guys can see how weird the last Boss Baby movie was.
Because that was the last Boss Baby movie I didn't watch.
It was the last one.
Oh, yeah.
You're missing out on the intro, by the way.
I got to see the intro.
Oh, whoa.
Okay, you saw the part that matters.
All right.
Wait.
Okay, let's grab.
Okay, let's see it again, because you guys missed it.
What is this?
Whoa!
Feet.
Wee!
I will say the oldest really pretty, but it's also so much clutter.
It's so much clutter.
Okay, customize.
Where's the yellow?
Oh, the other...
Oh, this one's pretty ugly, but...
I am ready to put on a show.
I would say this is really cute.
But it's also like a lot.
Wait, how do I afford this?
You need 200 more for...
Or spend two...
I can't afford that.
Alright.
I can't even afford it!
That was a lie!
Oh my god.
I need to spend another $5.
If I leveled up twice, I wouldn't have had to spend another $5.
dollars.
I don't have the battle pass.
I don't have it.
Guys, I never bought any of the battle pass.
Guys, I never bought any of the, I don't have it.
Free pass has a two.
Oh, guys, I forgot to open I didn't even open the battle pass, guys.
I don't think I have it.
Wait, where is it?
Is this?
Is it this?
Oh, it's luxury.
Oh, it's this.
Okay.
200.
Wait, I have 800.
I don't have...
800 wait what how do i not have 800 okay but like how do i not have 800 spend obtain 800 more how do i not have oh i have to exchange no no you don't okay i need to do all this oh i need 800 more oh wait i should be able to afford it now okay i do this for you guys wait i need a hundred okay that's a one dollar that's fine that's one i can afford i'll just buy another i'll just buy it that's just one dollar guys it's just It's just one dollar.
I'll do it for one dollar.
Okay.
There we go.
Bam.
Are you happy now?
Are you happy?
All right.
I can't do this though because I'm broke.
I don't have enough.
We don't get the ocean.
All right, queue us up.
Can a new wooden keyboard come out already?
So I can...
Queue.
I need a new wooden keyboard to come out because my current wooden keyboard is, like, fucked up right now.
It's actually...
My...
I don't know why, but my...
My alt key keeps falling off.
oh my god oh no oh it's broken oh wait this is bad
it's a little bit broken guys oh my god my keyboard is disgusting i need to clean it no why clean when i can get a new one don't worry the new wooden keyboard's coming out in quarterly four don't worry guys oh my oh key is a little broken right now but that's all right oh it's not okay it's not even on anymore like you know like the plus thing on the keys where so it can attach to the keycap um that's broken
that may or may not be broken i don't know how it broke guys i i don't know how it broke but it's it's two snapped in half the little thing so like that's an issue i i that may or may not be an issue guys that could be a a pretty big issue don't worry then you wouldn't keyboard in quarterly for oh my gosh it's literally like did I do anything with the alt key well it's on my alt key actually
is the alt key on anything important no I'm fine it's not on anything important
that's fine please go to a temple to key
guys you think I need to go guys you think I need to go to a temple bullets at wash when everything is on me right now.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
No, I've never played Half-Life 2.
Oh, we have a Spider-Man.
There we go.
No, we played...
What's it called?
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Buy a whole new keyboard for a keyboard.
cap is five five a dollar yeah me thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i played what's the other one black mesa yeah black mesa i played black mesa i just didn't play i didn't play uh half-life black
mesa was my the first stream you watch whoa what a throwback
This has to be third-party tracking.
It's like, who the fuck Bann's name more?
Black Mesa.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Because, like, I'm just thinking, like, who the fucking Bann's name right?
Gosh, I'm so close to Celestia.
I might do more rival grinding streams I've ranked on Twitch in the future.
I had to put a pause in that because I was always so busy.
But now, now, um, now I can go back to it.
Oh, Spider-Man.
Oh, yeah, right.
I forgot.
We have a Spider-Man.
I, like, blocked him from my mind.
Blue!
The blue Loki?
Disgusting!
Look, look,
he never has to swap off.
green why is he blue why is loki blue it's a crime it's a it's a crime you should be green here's the thing
he's sad i'm blue by oh i forgot to give him whoops i forgot to give the spider-man the He doesn't... it's fine.
He doesn't need to know.
I forgot.
Oh my gosh, it's a whole new sound effect too.
I have to reload.
I have to solo heal too.
Oh my god, everybody is solo!
Oh, I have to get used to the new sound effects too.
This is, they're all...
It's like all new healing sound effects and it throws me off a little because I'm not used to the...
Because I played Luna for so long, I'm not used to it.
Oh, she likes to close.
Just like... Oh, okay.
They're fine, right?
Yeah, she's fine.
Okay, just...
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
You're so healthy!
See?
Look at me go!
A thousand cuts!
I dance!
Nice combo, bro.
Are they coming?
I can't hear shit, man.
My music loud as fuck.
Damn.
No, not yet.
Okay, we gotta give Spider-Man.
Oh, you mean the GP, my god.
Spider-Man!
Fuck!
Okay, there you go.
I got him.
I hit like everybody else but the Spider-Man.
Oh, nice dude.
And you got a kill through it?
What the hell?
I literally healed everybody but that was...
Think, think, think, think, think, think, think, think, think.
Guys, he might never miss that.
I'm a little...
Oh, I'm definitely a little scared.
You think he's alive?
Oh my god, he's alive.
he's alive think can't jump think can't jump come to me he's one he's grown he missed I missed he had no shit you're my hero oh my god please he's not one shot that's a lot now he is oh my god oh my god oh i got i got messed up oh my god you sure did wait where's our low key wait where did he go oh he was dead hey that's on me guys sorry he's like i missed guys honestly if you hit it we will not that's so weird I've played Duna for so long,
so it's weird to listen to like a new, to new sound effects, you know?
I'm not used to it.
It's like when you play with a...
My god.
Which one's the right?
Someone save him, though.
Okay, I don't have to use it yet.
I have to use it now.
all right see this is what i mean oh my god please no yes wrong lunas don't worry he's five this is five we're alive we're alive I'm so sorry It's a guy It's a guy It's a guy It's okay We don't It's okay We don't talk about How he missed again I'll be back Let me change outfits Let me change outfits Give me a sec guys Gotta change some clothes Real quick I'll get to my closet They keep blocking my own Bro What can I say?
Sure Okay But like You can shoot around it Wow Shooting at around bro that's crazy that's crazy i don't i don't know what that means around oh my god i hate when the map changes from this air
i mean around i only know forward
i'm supposed to dps more on luno now we made a path to Okay.
Okay.
All right, that's fine.
Whoa!
What?
He got deleted.
Oh, he wants to kill me.
Oh, he's jumping.
He's trying to get the anger.
Nice.
Come on.
Someone save him.
I have my L2.
That's 5.
That's not 5!
That's not 5?
It's no longer 5 and he does have strange health.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Not me!
Oh no.
Maybe me though.
Wait, Spider-Man kills everything here.
I know he will.
I believe.
Oh, they lamp.
I know he will.
They lamp.
Oh, yes he will.
They lamp though.
Oh, fuck.
It's too late.
He double head.
He did that double heady.
Bro, okay, our Spider-Man is getting the absolute pocket of his fucking life though.
Hawkeye you're playing things you're playing thing into Hawkeye and I think he might have another moon that's just a maybe that's just a maybe though God it's so weird I'm sorry I it's so weird listening to these new sound effects for, uh, for this.
I'm not used to it at all.
No, no!
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm safe, I'm safe.
I'm so safe.
I feel so safe.
This is where I start fearing.
No!
I knew it.
I got Ulton.
I knew that was going to happen to me.
Please.
I'm here.
Come on, Spider-Man.
Me and you.
Me and you, Spider-Man.
Where is my Spider-Man?
Okay, okay, I was going to sit.
Me and you.
And I'm like, where are you?
Where did he go?
The timing was so bad.
Oh my god, okay.
That Punisher killed himself.
That Punisher actually fucked himself over there.
Yeah, I'm coming over.
Yo, NBC Squad.
Oh, look, he's good, actually.
What the hell is it good?
Nice.
Yeah, that was the good ass TP You need to swap The TP was good We worried about a hog dude I'm just shocked Go delete and spawn I was on the point while I portaled Before I died That TP was so fucking clutch That was a clutch ass TP literally saved Yeah I was like Taxi Yeah I was like taxi
got in in time our spider-man for some reason did not want to be on my yeah they don't run dive do they enjoy it wait this isn't yellow when i no it's blue okay i'll see it be i'll be so sad
it's blue guys thank you for the super chat kazuma thank you thank you yeah because of you're right it's because of me i clutched it i did this i'm gonna spam uh i'm gonna spam the play music i'm gonna play this slay list we have another oh we do where's our spider-man can i even reach him i can't bro i can't actually can't reach him i was trying my best to to reach.
Holy shit.
What was the point of being there?
Come over here, Spider-Man.
Give me pictures of Spider-Man.
He's a menace.
Oh my God.
Oh, you walled us off.
You walled off.
What the fuck?
Oh, don't put water.
Oh my God.
I don't think...
I don't think Adam's the pick, guys.
I...
I don't think Adam's...
I don't think Adam is the pick, guys.
I don't...
I didn't use the team-up because I didn't think I needed...
Oh, I wasted that team-up, too.
I didn't... I thought his shield was gonna...
Oh my god.
That sucks because both the supports are not.
Yeah, I have to die there.
I don't think Adam is the character to play.
Yeah.
I think the warlock was a little...
The warlock was a little...
Just a little bit...
Of a maybe a throw just maybe though.
I'm not sure yet.
Oh,
no Sounds like oh, no, no cuts Holy shit.
He's gone
He's gone Nice
Okay I don't want to peek that though.
I don't I'm not egoing that I'm not that crazy.
There you go.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We have, almost have Nokia.
We have a good support system.
A good, a good pattern.
We rotate us.
Oh my god, you're alive.
That guy is...
Ah!
Please.
You can copy whenever you want.
You can copy.
I'm literally right there.
I'm right here.
Just because I don't...
Yeah, I'm just... yeah.
Okay, Loki, you and I, we can live this together.
We didn't live this together.
Wait.
We didn't lose- I just think he died this fast, not gonna lie.
No, just- just play- let's play strange.
Play strange.
You won't get- you won't get shot.
It'll be a lot easier.
They're not playing bad birds.
Oh, we're gonna run down because we have no like- We were running Adam Warlock and had no healing.
Now we're just gonna run down- He swapped off after first point.
No, that's the- that's the worst excuse.
They've been winning because they're old.
They've had better olds than me.
I mean, we don't have a shield for the Hawkeye.
Oh my god.
We got Groot!
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm trying to...
Oh my.
I'm so scared.
Our poor mag.
Oh my god.
Our poor team.
Oh, I was like, they're putting Wanda and you're dying to try to make them swap.
Um, but...
How far?
How far do I have to be?
I felt like I was going so far.
I felt like I was so far.
We're playing double dive into Wanda.
Can we swap?
I legitimately stuck.
Oh, no, this is for the Hawk guy.
Oh my god, that would have been so clutch if I hit that freeze.
That would have been so clutch if I hit that I thought I was far enough Oh my I'm so sad If I hit that freeze that would have been clutch as hell Loki, Loki, Loki, Loki, Loki, Loki The current score is three two three time to switch things up including which oh man i'm luna snow like guys i don't think we're winning this this kid might be a curse this kid may be a curse guys i think wanda counters dive and we're going double dive well okay first off what makes you think that wanda is good against my character tell me he's he's rank bigger man No,
you hold left click.
That's it.
The- what is the- where's the fundamentals of it?
He's- He's a rake player.
The character fucking blows.
It doesn't matter that she- that the character counters me.
And the character doesn't.
You're- you're such a rage baiter.
What do you mean one that doesn't counter die?
He's a- Dude, the character is bad!
It's a bad character!
He doesn't do anything!
It's only for characters who can't aim.
Okay, maybe surely for Spider-Man it will be easier to- kill them out of the air but at the same time the the value that the character does is like nothing no but she doesn't do anything against me she doesn't she does a little bit against spider-man It doesn't do anything to me.
I don't think Wanda was a problem.
You don't have nothing to back yourself.
Stop it.
Quit raging.
Listen.
Would you be quit raging?
You're rage baiting me.
I'm not rage baiting.
I'm just, I'm calming and telling you.
You're getting countered by a...
It's not a counter.
What the fuck was this fucking spoiler?
You walk into the back line and then you get a lot of luck on me.
No.
Who, do you have a coach?
Are you, have you been taught the game?
What are you talking about?
Oh my god, what are you talking about?
Do you have a coach?
When you die?
Nice.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I want to give the...
Do you have a coat?
Dude, they...
Oh, they don't know.
Oh, I didn't think we should have used that.
Because they can still portal in.
But they didn't, thank God.
They didn't portal in, that's good.
Oh, they have four minutes.
Jesus Christ.
They actually have four minutes for this.
I'm scared.
I go to back leg now.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god.
I have to back up too.
I'm not gonna risk it.
Oh my god, she's so...
She's so, she's on fucking huge counter.
Absolutely.
Oh, what?
Yeah.
Okay.
I just saw it.
I saw you put your nuts on the on the Wanda, but he counted you though Four three two I don't know who I'm giving the count out to myself I give the countdown to myself guys Mike I have to know when I'm like who am I counting it for it?
It's for me.
I need to remind myself what deal is It's back.
It's back.
It's for us.
Yeah.
oh my god it's one second guys i'm so scared i don't want to get off because i feel like we're gonna see nine if i do leave okay let's hope that my team doesn't see nine that's like the one thing i hope for take over tonight oh
my god i tried my best i tried my best my low-key oh my god we had a copy i'm so sad
i got um no we could have we could have had like the preemptive luna little like copy that's where we're walking in you don't have it okay you could have just had that first that's unlucky i literally got arrowed at the end there It was right there.
Can I have a coach?
I'm not very good at this game.
That's so funny.
That's the point, Meg.
That's good.
I was thinking, yeah, our Meg was most definitely not the one.
The problem.
At least he was.
I was fine.
definitely the item pick was a little bit of a troll he's rage we're all rage baiters oh never mind
yeah now you guys know what
duck thank you with the super chat thank you thank you
I feel like I'm just gonna randomly log here.
That's why I'm like scared.
I'm trying to knock it accidentally arrowed.
Okay, they don't have Hawkeye, so I don't have to be as scared, which is nice.
Okay.
Oh, reload!
Try and do as much damage as I can!
And also hit!
What the fuck?
I'm at 94, so I'm trying.
He's so close.
Oh my god, he blocked it!
I don't have to be center stage.
I actually blocked it!
Okay, I have the ult for the strange.
I have the ult for the strange.
So, let's hope I don't get a strange ult.
The little things.
Let's hope I don't get a strange ult, guys.
I can have good reflexes, but he could come from the fucking sky, and I would not notice.
That's, like, the scary part.
Like, he could come from anywhere.
Like, see?
Like, that's what I mean.
He could...
Oh, please!
Please shoot me!
Oh, my God!
Thank you!
I sometimes like dance around the back.
just in case.
Just just in case that, you know, he's like, I'm here!
I'm here!
Look at me!
Okay.
Gotta make sure he sees me, you know?
There you go.
I'm a hero!
Okay.
We're heroes.
That mag was like, where is she?
Where is she?
I'm here.
I'm here in front of you.
I'm a hero.
Watch your sword.
Why did he not play at Hawkeye?
He was so good at Hawkeye.
Not gonna lie.
I felt like he was actually like doing so much for his team.
Like him not all around Hawkeye is actually strong.
I swear to God, unless he's throwing Unless he got yelled at and decided to throw I mean sometimes that happens when you get yelled at You're just like, you know what?
Fuck you I'm not that desperate to win Hey guys Hey guys Hey guys
I'm scared.
Why am I?
Why was it me?
What?
I don't know where I couldn't go anywhere.
Oh, they see not!
Yay!
I was like, there was nowhere to go.
I ain't saying shit.
There was nowhere to go!
I was stuck in the corner.
We did it.
See, the skin is in a curse.
Yeah, they see nine.
They send nine.
No, that's it.
Yay.
I thought he was going to look at the other Luna.
On her counter us, bro.
She swapped by the way.
She's so hot, by the way.
Bring it water.
All right, no.
Guys, if I was streaming, you guys would have heard me, like, screaming at my mic the entire time.
All right.
This guy pissed me the fuck off.
I'm back.
I can change the sound effects?
Okay.
I need to change it.
I hate...
Man, that Magneto was way better than me.
True, you could have not for the one.
The counter!
Bro.
Alright, let's see.
Bro, is he okay?
Is this like...
Does he have like a fucking...
Bro, are you okay, buddy?
Why are you so...
So sad.
Ooply dooply.
All right.
They are in GM.
That's why they're shot.
They're shot little guys.
There's one that countered him.
I mean, like a Loki cloak and dagger.
A band torch.
Oh, yeah.
I do have this.
All right.
The only thing I don't like, I like the skin, but, like, his robe covers everything.
So that's why I go presidential.
Because there's no point.
His robe covers everything, so there's no point.
I don't know.
I don't, I like, I don't like the robe as much.
I don't like this robe as much as this.
This one, look, this reminds me of Tom Hilton more.
I'll just remind you of Tom Hilton more.
That's why I like it more.
I will lie.
I'm direct.
Okay, bro.
Okay.
It's the classic Loki.
With the slick back hair.
And everything.
It's a classic.
That's how you really feel.
I was a Tom Hilsson girl on Tumblr.
I told you guys.
I won't lie.
I know what I am.
I know my past.
Oh my god, this map again.
I literally just finished this map.
Okay, we're back.
Loud and proud.
Actually shameless Hey, hey, I wasn't a super Was it super hula girl at least At least I never stoop below super hula Because I never watched Doctor Who I watched like a bits and episodes of it But but when they like When Kavit Tenet wasn't the doctor anymore I didn't enjoy it anymore I'm sorry I don't like the other doctor,
whoever, whichever one that was.
I wasn't a...
What?
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about...
You don't have to know about Super Hula.
You don't...
Don't worry.
You don't need to know.
Holy shit.
Wooply.
Exploded.
Oh my god.
exploded I might have to go I might have to go something else I mean I almost have up though holy shit I healed as much as I could all right that's fine
all right
But this is why you do confirmation
That's my bad.
That's I just noticed it.
I just noticed it.
That was my bad.
Okay, I would admit I fucked up there I actually
Like who I was saying is I I will admit I threw that I hundred percent threw that Oh my god okay no I I agree I agree I'm picking up that I forgot where I was for a sec
That was my bad I think that was my bad I was actually my bad I actually fucked up there I will admit I messed up I should swap this is why I don't have lord icon on this is why I don't have a lord icon okay
Look, I... I know I messed up.
Okay.
I will not do that mistake again.
I think you can tell I also have not played Cloak in...
Your powers are mine!
I never had to play Cloak in so long, too.
That's the thing.
I never had to play with a play at Cloak.
Jesus Christ it's fine it's okay we're oh no I'm just getting beat up it's okay I didn't fuck up now though I didn't I didn't fuck up now I we we only had we get one fuck up okay I don't know how I lived I felt like I getting smacked non-stop but i never had to play cloak because cloak is like not okay you know not really a character you have to play i thought i literally didn't think i had to i thought he was didn't die that fast but that's Alright,
I'm gonna take that.
Guys!
Ooh!
Guys, can you guys push the cart?
Guys!
Looking pretty cool!
To have the cart pushed!
Thank you guys!
You know what would be pretty awesome!
Alright, nice.
I don't know how the fuck he died, but nice.
I hear someone above me.
I don't like it.
Oh, it's my Hella.
Please tell me I can...
That... nice.
There's a...
There's a guy behind my.
That... Oh, that's the enemy Hella.
Look at that!
We did it!
Again!
Look at that!
Yippee!
I did it!
I'm a hero.
As always.
A hero.
I don't have any emotes.
Oh, I should have healed.
Sorry, I was too busy gloating.
I was too busy letting everyone know what kind of person I am.
Yeah.
Our cloak should push up to build up.
Because I already have my...
so she should push her up see look at that i'm a team player i wish she did that for me but i need it up
i guess i don't matter come on that'll be fine that guy's not gonna be fine but like the rest of us will be fine though there so we can live so we can all live oh my god okay i where did she land i think she hit the ceiling i i actually i think she hit the ceiling because i was like where is she i'm supposed to land with her that was wild that's unfortunate Because I was like,
where did she go?
Oh, hey, there's the Iron Fist.
There was the Iron Fist.
Okay, I go the other side, I guess.
Fuck my.
Fuck my shift, Pete.
That's unfortunate.
Oh, that's very unfortunate.
Oh.
that's sad oh that's sad it's okay we still have one more fight i leave now not looking back oh my god why did i look back
oh my god i'm i'm staying in here i'm i'm staying in here i i don't care about healing any of you guys oh i thought he was gonna keep his shield back down.
I think they're gonna moon very soon.
It feels very moon-like environment.
Yeah.
Can we touch it?
Because I'm one.
Oh my god, that's unlucky.
It's okay.
They have strange ult.
Three.
And then, as long as I don't get strange ult, that's five.
He fell?
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Oh, man.
That's...
Oh, that's awkward.
It's okay, I guess.
It's you and I.
It's okay.
It's oh, never mind How did the Phoenix spawn?
He fell Where did he go?
Where did our Phoenix go?
Maybe Emma kicked them out.
I hope to God that's what happened Okay, do we do it?
it yeah okay maybe not after what happened to me after after what happened to me when i close up i don't know i don't know okay maybe i'll try again i'll try i'll try again maybe Maybe it won't be as bad.
Maybe it won't be bad.
What's a jokie bird?
It's a bird.
Guys, maybe this time it won't be as embarrassing.
I just don't copy cloaks.
It's so rare to play with a cloak.
Actually, I think I fucked it up.
Yeah, I think I fucked it up.
I don't know where to put my clones here.
I definitely fucked that up.
I don't know how to play defensive Loki here.
Like the placements of the stuff.
I should like...
Oh, I should have done what the other...
The Loki on my team was doing last game.
He like knew how to play Loki.
really good at it too.
I have many faces.
Yeah.
That was for me.
Because he put in like...
He put in like all...
One was like back here.
And I guess one was like in the front.
I think that's how he put it.
It was farther up but they destroyed them.
Yeah.
I wanted to live.
I was fine.
But thank you.
There you go.
Oh, fuck.
I did not realize our guy was so far.
It didn't let me press F.
Oh, no.
That's unfortunate.
It's okay.
We have Porta.
I pressed F and it didn't let me do it.
So I was like, what the fuck?
Where is...
Where's my cloak?
I'm trying to find my cloak.
Where is she?
Okay.
That's fine.
I was like, where is she?
Where's the blonde woman?
It was so hard.
There's too many blonde women.
Where's my blonde women?
I quit.
I was like looking around.
I was like, where is she?
There's so many blonde women in this game.
Where's mine?
Holy shit.
I got scared.
Oh!
How do I live that?
I don't know!
I was not living that.
I was definitely not living that.
Bro, that was...
That was scary.
There was nothing I could do there.
Literally, I was...
I could not even see the moon.
The light force is getting stronger.
You need to stop that vehicle in its train.
I'm definitely, like, not really good at killing placements here.
Let's engage the world.
Bro, fuck off.
Okay.
I mean, my lamps are working, I think.
I don't think I have to use it yet.
Yeah, I didn't think I had to use it after you reload, though.
He literally didn't know.
I'm everywhere.
Live!
Okay, nice, we live.
Yeah, he caught me in a dark alley.
He caught me in crime alley.
They put crime...
I don't know what to do.
I was in crime alley.
Okay.
Just in case.
I...
Oh my god.
What do I do now?
This!
Oh!
Ah!
He was following me everywhere!
Survive.
Mission successful.
Mission very successful.
Oh my god, he went to the wrong clone.
Ha ha, loser.
That was my clone, brother.
That's right.
You got the clone.
Guys.
Guys, he wants to kill me.
Oh my god.
That was something I used every.
cool down I had.
It was literally every cool down possible to get there.
There was nothing else I could do.
I used everything.
I actually used all my cool down for that.
Oh my god, you're alive.
I don't know how.
Okay, bomb.
Okay.
I have to.
Oh!
I took one down with me!
I took him down.
Oh, shit.
I took all the matches.
I thought you would hate it.
I lived.
I took down two feet.
down with me this game is easy no not seeing the trickster guy I went through a D day there you hit every button I actually went through a D day holy shit I should not have been alive I really should not have lived there oh my god you get it from what before i used to play it wouldn't be that good for that thor it wouldn't be fucking oh hey nice dad mentioned that thor wanted me fucking dead wait i need to see i need to see that again
all right well how that was so i took you out no no that's not me oh i died no but in central park yeah i was going through nom in central park that was a crazy fight which hero do you think you want to be today i felt like i used every cooldown i had for that fight
let's see what a game i'm surprised I'm surprised.
I'm surprised I brought someone down with me twice.
I killed people twice
I'm a gamer
Why do you think I never played healers unless I'm in a mood?
I'm not going down.
That's right.
I take one down with me I swear I was going like a fucking merry-go-round.
I don't know.
Black Panther?
No one bans.
I ban him.
Alright.
Okay.
We go together.
Oh no.
Are they Loki or Luna?
Oh, they give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I'm Luna snow like the moon who is what do we play I'm Luna snow like the moon okay whoopi doesn't even have the swimsuit what's the point what's the point when you don't even have the swimsuit fucking stupid
Every person is so smart In terms of like selling skins Because like Like first person you can barely tell If you have like a sick ass skin
He's not gonna buy Luna skin on all of them Weak as fucking hell That sounds like someone who's weak as hell That's all I'm seeing
Only...
Not a real one.
Alright.
I shouldn't... I used it way too early.
I used it so early.
It's fine.
Just let him poke me.
I'm literally... Oh my god, it's not fine anymore!
It is not fine anymore!
I saw my HP drop.
so much it's no longer fun i do not feel i do not feel healthy i do please oh my god i i have to use this i did no longer felt healthy i actually no longer my you reflected himself i lived they're thirsty for you what the fuck i lived i i whoa They had a moon laser
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up
That's actually fucked up I am ready to put on a show Please touch No I tried
I tried so hard.
I'm getting out of here.
I'm leaving.
This is a mess.
This is truly a mess.
There's so many things going on.
But I don't know what to do anymore.
we heal each other and then we can keep each other alive we can keep each other i i'm just gonna eat up in the corner um oh my god that's so fucked up holy i'm just i'm just gonna get up in the corner grew one hb grew hb absolutely absolutely i got stuffed in the locker i i don't why counter that what is the counterfeit all right i ain't gonna lie getting an ultron would be fantastic right now what what would have been the counterfeit what yeah it's showing we just need my mom this is from a dive oh my god oh my god we're just barely in the lap we're barely
Where?
No!
Okay, I'll go suit.
I'll go suit.
Yeah, swap.
I'm opening a portal.
I can't.
I'm sorry, he's gonna be the one that's gonna get beat up.
Because I can't.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do.
I run them.
If they run.
They can't see me.
They can't bully me.
Oh my god.
No, I think this might be GG's.
This is this hard dive is.
Also, their comp is useless if we go cap too.
Holy shit.
I play cap, but I don't know if one of you want to swap.
Cap.
Oh my god.
Please.
We can babysit each other.
okay okay it's fine
it's okay
all right can't get me if i'm invisible he can't oh my it's not just the captain no no you don't understand it's the captain and the iron fist Like, did you not see what they did to me in that corner?
Did you...
That was actually a hate crime.
Like, that was a hate crime towards women.
We're dead.
We're...
I'm dead.
That team...
We can live this if I also had my sudo by it.
Oh my god.
I don't know if we live this.
Guys.
Okay, now I know for sure I'm getting heavily targeted.
Now, guys, guys, guys, we can live this.
We can live, we can just live this.
I just want to be alive.
It's fine.
Now I know I'm definitely getting targeted.
Now I- Now I know!
Now I know!
I was like, damn!
I sure am getting heavily focused there!
Wow!
Pretty weird!
That's happening to me!
It's pretty fucking weird!
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
I...
What's going on?
Oh my god, get out of here.
Get out of here.
I'm alive.
I actually need a raise.
I'm doing so much.
I... I'm... I...
Oh my god.
I'm alive.
I'm alive!
I'm not laughing.
Oh my god, he's gaming.
He's actually gaming.
This is a strong-ass wall that I can't break.
Okay.
Someone break this wall, please.
They built that wall.
They're gonna use that moon thing.
I can feel it.
Oh, in this first, in this first, in this first.
Okay.
I fucked up.
Bad.
They're going to Groot all after this.
I can feel it.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I was not living that.
That's okay.
We have extermination.
Okay.
Where is...
Okay, there it is.
Oh, we don't have extermination.
Oh, we did.
God, please, I have to reload.
Please.
I have to reload.
I'm sorry!
Oh, my God.
Please.
Fly up.
Fly up in the end.
Go for a hold.
Oh!
Please, I can't!
One last fight.
Drizzle!
No!
He got frozen!
He actually got frozen!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Please.
Please!
No!
Oh, I needed him to...
I needed...
We'll play to heal me there.
If he healed me, we...
I could have ulted.
I actually needed that heal.
Oh, it will be healing me there.
Instead of running away from me.
I could have had my...
That's crazy.
The amount that I am doing right now, I'm going to keep playing Luna.
Holy shit.
It was so tragic.
The one time I didn't get babysat.
That's so sad.
when I was this close.
No, Wooply was next to me, but then he ran to the left.
He literally ran to the left.
He was next to me.
And he didn't run away.
I could have lived and got my queue.
There's like nearly one mistake that caused it.
okay that was crazy this i'm getting i'm actually getting heavy retargeted
yeah yeah but if we bait we just needed to babysit each other after that is if we if we both babysat each other i could have got my own keep playing uh cap that's just like op op actually against that never mind no i mean you can do this Try raising two super-powered kids.
And sometimes you'll be like that, you know, like the one mistake.
They literally just one mistake.
I have to use...
Jesus Christ, there's so much...
So much damage.
Oh my god, I'm like just holding left click.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
The amount of healing we're both doing.
That's a fucking W key.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, wait, they're on triple, like 3.5 tank now.
Where we actually can't do anything.
Oh, this is awkward.
Well, they're not dead, so I can swap off.
Actually, I can.
Yeah, I can swap off.
Okay.
Dude, what do I play against that?
I'm like, what the...
Okay.
Okay, here you go.
No worries, I've got your back.
Aww, that's unlucky.
Okay, we gotta kill this guy.
Alright, we still have my...
Yeah!
I gotta TP, TP on point, TP on point, TP on point.
Okay.
Oh, not on point?
What the fuck TP is that?
Like, what the fuck?
I have to use that.
Jesus Christ, this damage.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I think he's gonna walk up to me.
So, I was like, no, this guy is absolutely...
We can get off Ultron now, then we can just go storm.
Okay.
Here, uh, I'll let you swap the storm or do you not know how to play it?
No, you can play it.
I'll go.
All right.
Here we go.
Now that there's no dive, maybe it'd be like less scary.
Like, I got it.
Maybe it would be like less scary.
Here we go.
Maybe it would be less scary.
Like...
Anarchy.
There we go.
We save each other.
Look at that.
We babysit each other.
Let's go.
Yeah, whenever people do a triple tank, I just go to Thor.
I don't know why it works.
No, it doesn't work.
He's like, I don't know if it works.
And he's like, it doesn't work.
How dare you think it works?
It actually does not
Do I have okay, I do okay, I do thank God
Okay, there's no one to other This is bad
Oh my god, fuck, okay, this is this is like this is all there It's basically...
It's basically a support off.
It's a support off.
If you think it's a support off.
It's... Well, it works.
It works.
The thing is, Captain America's honor is also a support off.
It still works.
I didn't fuck up.
It's okay.
It's still...
It's still supporting.
It's...
Massive play.
Yeah, I didn't fuck up because technically it's still a support It's Technically it still is
Like as long as it works Oh my god But I don't know how long I can be alive for it Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I believe.
Oh my god, please stop strafing.
Please stop strafing.
Ok.
Alright.
I'll let the Luna off first.
Just in case!
Oh my God!
Where is he?
Just in case!
Oh my god, just a kiss.
Just a whop, sorry.
I am so sorry.
I had to figure out how to protect you all.
Please.
He's one, please.
I tried so hard to protect everybody.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're alive.
I heard that moon and I got worried.
I still hit the ground.
Holy shit, what's going on over there?
Guys, what the fuck is going on over there though?
Okay, the only bad thing is that he's farming.
He's definitely farming all this right now.
Goodbye.
Okay, I am farming a lot of upcharge.
Okay, this is a little worrisome because they definitely have the moon and I'm...
Oh, poor dude.
Will he live?
Okay, he...
I mean, interesting play.
Oh, please, please keep me up.
I mean, I guess it's an interesting play.
No!
Oh, that's so unfortunate.
That was nothing.
That's so, I'm fucking, I'm coming over guys.
I'm coming over!
Get near me.
Get near me, please.
Please get near me, get near me, get near me.
Get near me.
No, are you...
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
Guys, I don't think we're going to win this.
Guys, I don't know.
I do.
Guys, it does not look so hopeful.
Again?
Guys, I have.
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling there.
How hard is Faka?
That was, yeah.
Again.
It's because we were all grouped up.
We were all grouped up together because it was last fight.
So he instantly got all after that.
I mean, the smart decision was to swap off Loki, but we needed their first healing.
That was the thing.
Like, I literally did 53- Jesus Christ.
I did 53k healing when we had triple support.
Guys, the enemy team did 47k healing with double support.
We had triple support and I still got 53k healing.
Holy fuck.
That's crazy.
Yeah, no, that- I was not- I was like...
I was not gonna live.
Wait, what did we want to watch?
It was something we wanted to watch.
What did we want to watch earlier?
Yeah, we were not winning that.
No, absolutely not.
No, no, no.
We wanted to watch something.
Oh, and Nam.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Now I have my PTSD there.
The PTSD came.
Okay.
Where was this?
Where was Nam?
It was right here.
Was it?
Or was it?
Was it this?
No, this was me dancing.
No, this was here!
This was Nam!
I mean, all they did was chase me down.
Okay.
That was crazy.
though i was not gonna live i'm luna snow like the moon i sure he's gonna be on support who am i gonna vanish from this i'm banning i'm over me oh i guess because we're on group yeah make sense
no no don't don't make a cutout on me um i'm banning porch We have a dive and I'm...
Oh, it's nice.
I had like 18 deaths, mother, BS, I signed up.
Everyone got mad at him.
Everyone got mad at him?
Wait, why would we get rid of Emma if they go dive?
Yo, I can't hear anything you're saying, bro.
Why would...
I'll just type it.
Why would we go Emma if he's scared of dive?
Emma counters dive are you fucking stupid are you oh they're not playing dive they ban the panther you see are you stupid why would you be scared then why did you bet Emma peel because I peel because I get targeted by why would you bet yeah hopefully what are you playing bro
he is dps
yeah i don't want to i don't want to like blow it around the card but i do play i do play this game really well on dps i don't trust you bro i'll trust you you got it i trust you 30 seconds before you attack get ready all right the smart is i i can play I can play,
uh, fans of the Pio character.
Like, we don't have Pio now.
He was the one that chose Emma, too.
Is this Coth?
Yeah, this is Coth.
I trust him.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Moon Knight and group combo.
I mean, if you're good at Hawkeyes, then Hawkeye.
hello everybody all right because he's gonna bleed
okay we're gonna play until Celestia I want to get Celestia and besides guys we have so many we're we're so behind a lot of streams
okay where what is our I'm so...
Yeah, I'm like...
Where's our Groot?
Like, why is he still up top?
I'm just like, where is he?
He's still like, he has the high ground still.
Okay.
There we go.
He needs to win that 1v1.
I was so confused, I was like, bro, what the fuck Come down, get down here.
Get down here!
You're a tree!
You're not meant to flat!
Jesus.
Okay.
Okay, I hope he doesn't die.
I hope he doesn't die.
I am ready to put on a show.
Okay, I think all right, I had to I was so scared for our route Oh my god, how did I how did I where's my I'm up here now.
I'm down here now Okay, that's awkward
That's a little awkward but that's okay life is all about Happy accidents
Goodbye.
No more happy accidents.
Why do we all drop down when I had...
You know, there's so many questions.
Did I hit that?
No, I didn't.
Wait, did I?
I can't tell.
God, I need to change the sound effects.
I hate it.
I hate these sound effects.
Oh,
I missed it.
Fuck!
I'm not hitting my freezes right now.
I'm messing up.
Where did I...
Where did Wooply go?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're feeding a little bit, guys.
We may or may not be throwing...
I was like, I fucking hate playing against Hello Namur.
That's like my one weakness.
Hey, I'm up here.
Where's our Loki?
Hey, we're up here now.
I don't know how I got up here.
I mean, sweet.
I'm like, nice.
I don't know how I got up there, but nice.
Wait, where did our group go?
All right, I'm gonna come push Here we go I'm pushing I'm pushing oh That's awkward That's actually awkward There we go We have to fight with this Oh, we have to fight with this Whoa, oh, that's awkward That's awkward that wait what that doesn't freeze that should have froze oh that's so awkward
he he didn't do his little he didn't use his little little stranger pretty sad all right can i play dps yeah no brother i go ahead i fucking hate playing against that okay let's see how do i change The Luna thing.
I hate it.
I actually hate it so much.
How do I change it, guys?
Does anyone know?
Combat?
In the skins tab?
There's a skins tab?
Where's that?
In cosmetics?
What the fuck is that?
i think i think uh squirrel girl you just say i think squirrel girl is good here oh outside matches okay the battle starts in five wait like we're on one tank with mantis heals like it's just gg i guess all you need to do is capture the mission area like a job wait fantastic even if it's like this work okay i'm putting this on the grude i guess Mr. Fantastic?
I mean, I mean...
Okay.
Okay, I think I hit it.
It looked like I hit it.
I think I hit it.
Okay, that's not my...
That's not me.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We did it.
Mr. Fantastic!
Alright.
Okay, it's okay.
I'll get the... I hate it.
It's just such a weird sound when...
There you go.
That was a good freeze.
Look at that.
I did it.
Okay, now... Oh, nice.
That's good.
Okay, okay, buddy.
Did it solve the problem?
That sucks.
I needed... Yeah.
I literally needed And we lost our Luna And just save olds there, bro That was so unfortunate I was behind Wooply, so he didn't know I was low
It was just that unlucky There was nothing I could do there Literally It was just unlucky Because like Phoenix can two tap Really?
Really?
Thanks so much.
Her Phoenix kit.
Oh my god.
I had to use this for us.
Do we have shield?
Do we?
Yes.
We still live.
Thank God.
I think it's literally GG.
I think this team is like...
Oh, this is where I died.
I think this team was just not meant to live.
I don't think this team was meant to win in any capacity.
I...
holy shit we all do brother I literally if I can poke one time I'm fucked like he wants me oh my god I'm I'm fucking oh my god um please please please come over
guys I don't I think it's literally a Team diff.
I think it's literally a team diff, guys.
No, this is absolutely a team diff.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
That's so unlucky.
No, this is a team diff right there.
No, this team is just better.
This team is actually just betting.
Yeah, that wasn't it.
That wasn't it.
Okay, I realize I'm at almost a five-hour mark.
Wooply told me to let him DPS and then sold on DPSs.
You see, the problem is he didn't let him tank.
That's the problem.
Oh, my other showcrest is Celestia.
I don't
think I think it would I don't think I get that addicted again Oh we have Mr. Fantastic Loki time I'm gonna pee I'll be back I need some bathroom I'm back who am I gonna banish from this match
I'm back I'm back I'm back.
It's okay.
I don't need to change it because I don't have to play Luna.
Alright, it's not an addiction.
It's a lifestyle.
Why should I do Loki?
Okay.
Alright, I'll play.
I'll play until the 5-hour mark.
And then I'll call it today.
Tomorrow's Battlefield 6!
Alright, guys.
Tomorrow's Battlefield 6.
Also, I wasn't supposed to play this now.
but I got carried away as always.
I don't know what it is about rank.
I can just play rank forever.
It's just a competitiveness of me.
I could literally just play this game.
I could play any competitive game forever, like for a very long time if I don't, if I don't, no one stops me.
If no one stops me, I could play tank.
I could play even longer.
Yo, Strange, you play tank?
You see the- Yeah, I actually bought this icon on wish.com.
Can we play strange like the entire game?
No, I'm gonna portal us.
I bought this icon on wish.com.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Follow my portal?
Whoa, whoa, I'm body blocking.
My skinny eyes?
Look at you skinny ass twink body's gonna body block.
The perfect body block.
I don't know, I think if anybody in body blocks, it's definitely not the no key.
But I'll do it.
I'll do it for the team.
There you go down, come down.
You have to destroy now.
There you go.
I'm everywhere.
Invigorating, no.
Mine didn't hit me.
I accept this.
Oh, I fucked up.
I should not have done that.
I didn't think like you would know I'd be here Because I wanted to separate the supports a little bit because I can still heal ring Jesus Christ how much
Okay Okay, yeah, I had my ult first
Jesus Christ, I had to use that.
Please, kill him!
Oh my god, what is she doing here?
Kill him.
I live.
Okay, we have five alts.
I literally, we guaned that with just my alts.
Look at that.
I'm gaming.
And that's how you know.
gaming.
Yippee!
I'm gaming.
We got this.
I'm not healing anybody right now.
But I am gaming.
She is in fact sire gaming.
She'll be fine, right?
Oh wait, he's won.
Okay, that was embarrassing.
All right, don't worry, we got this.
That's how you know.
Okay, I need a note to remember to set these guys up in high ground.
I already have an almost another ult.
Nice.
Okay, he's gonna have some wild shit.
I was gonna press shift.
I literally pressed shift too.
I'm so sad.
I had shift.
Wait, we did it.
Yeah, I'm not sad anymore.
I'm not sad anymore.
We did it.
I'm gonna...
We kill her.
Yippee.
No longer sad.
I am no longer sad.
It's sad God.
It's just that easy.
Depression cured.
You know how they're like, well, how are you sad?
Just stop being sad.
That's what they mean.
That's how...
Guys, please!
I'm point, I'm point.
I'm pointy.
Get out of here.
I don't need help.
I cured depression.
Can he like...
Can he save him?
I don't know.
All right,
I'm ready to put on a show.
I'm ready.
What the fuck?
I'm so ready.
There we go.
Okay, wait, what?
Okay, don't worry.
My twink body shall body block you.
Don't worry.
Okay, who cares about whooply, though?
Did he do it?
Focus on him?
There we go.
Oh, it's Hawk.
Hawk time.
Oh, my God.
He got deleted.
We needed this game.
He disappeared.
Yeah, I was like, where did he go?
Actually shredded.
Yeah, the portal cut off all the supports.
That's right, guys.
I'm a hero.
The skinniest boy here.
Here the body block.
I'm a hero.
That's right.
That's how I got one above us.
Yippee.
The twink is gaming once again.
Okay.
Okay, but you guys can't lie.
Loki was around a lot.
He knew what he wanted.
Wait.
put my cool down he was around a lot oh fuck
oh that's awkward that's awkward he had a wildlife yeah his gap year never ended
wait oh I was gonna say why is he just standing there He was wild.
He was a wild man.
A wild twink.
That's fine.
Things are fine.
Things seem very fine.
That's not above it.
Drop down!
Why didn't you drop down?
You could have dropped down!
Go in, go in, go in!
Okay, three, two, oh no!
Oh no!
Oh, no.
Goodbye.
Who are you in portal?
No.
Oh, my God, we can't.
Oh, hey.
It's okay.
He died for the cause.
No, no.
That was so disrespectful.
What the fuck is this cop?
Adam, Jeff, Luna?
What a fucking weird-ass cop.
This is the comp of, like, desperate people.
oh my god he just fucking collapsed crazy i need to put in high ground nice okay i don't know how i got that but i'll take it good good luck to me i guess it's fine i need to put my clone high ground but like i'm just trying to live right now trying to make sure my team live
i'm just i'm just shooting what do you mean kill you you're you're fucking full hp jeff one jeff one can't hit me when i'm invisible he missed okay many faces yeah Aww, I can't we anymore.
Fine, we're fine.
Dude, Jeff, well, yeah.
Okay.
See, my team's okay.
My team's, my team is so healthy.
Where's that?
Oh, he is.
This guy misses every shot, but hits the headshot when I need it.
like where did he go where did he where did he go he disappeared so fast he's like he was just guys what the fuck bro okay he is getting deleted there we
Oh my god, do you think he's okay?
Do you think, oh, he's okay.
He's okay.
Do you think Luna is alive?
You think it's okay, he's okay.
Luna live.
I was like, oh my.
my god because i'm hitting all of them right here bro we got like yeah bro we got rag doll please um please oh my god i literally i had to use that i had to use that just for a you saw me like walk in front of him i was like please just a little crumb just a little crumb i think you think he'll I know you have his.
He's alive.
Oh, that's unlucky.
He's not alive anymore.
Wait, we still have Luna.
Bro, what are you saving it for?
We can back up.
We can touch with two support goals.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, use it for the most...
Okay, nice.
I was going to say, use it the moment I actually have.
You're alive!
Okay.
Okay, maybe I shouldn't have used that.
But I saved her.
I saved her, though.
I saved her.
I...
I saved her!
Whoa, got the arrow.
Wait, wait, have no support holes, I think.
I, I'm a hero!
Remember what I did!
That's awkward.
She's alive.
She appreciates it.
We're gonna get bubbles too, so I...
I am ready to put on a show!
That's fine, that's fine.
Just burst.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I need a backup though.
I need a backup of this.
That's awkward.
That's whoa!
It's okay.
Whoa.
We are looking.
We do!
Get in here!
Okay, um...
Oh,
hey guys!
Hey guys!
Hey
guys!
Why did we all leave me alone?
On the point!
Why did you all leave?
Guys!
Why did you all leave me?
I was not expecting that.
I was just like, hello, everybody.
We can't.
I think we win this.
I think they chased the fish.
Yeah, I was just like, hey guys.
Nice.
See that.
Sometimes you get to throw this down.
Where'd everybody go?
We picked up everybody, but Tokyo's just, I just saw my other two teammates just walk the way for the jump.
I was like, guys, guys, you're still, guys, five other people are going to, look, we're going to beat me up, guys.
Oh yeah, change the sound effect.
You're right, you're right.
you'll come back right you'll come back right all right let's uh heroes uh god damn it i was just about to do it where did they all go Tommy salami oh if it was named with salami that would be great i think it was supposed to be but someone already took salami.
Refused to switch.
We're bad in our character.
That'll be the best part.
I mean, he's gonna go with Luna.
Alright, Omega.
Johnny!
Get him out of my game!
Nobody likes you.
That's why you die.
And Spider-Man took your place.
That's why I said it.
Spoilers.
It's literally in like the Marvel Rivals intro.
But came back.
Nobody actually dies, dies.
In any superhero universe.
Oh.
Mining cleaner.
What's called Punisher?
All right, fine.
Go.
Okay, well, that was not exhibited.
This guy didn't even mention fucking Phoenix.
All right.
Yeah.
Poor villain.
I'm not judging.
I don't mind going up against a group.
I can charge my beam off his walls.
Except for...
No, no.
Batman brought the math.
There's actually a story where Batman...
brings back his parents but they're like zombies and then like everyone else was like you gotta like you gotta kill them and that man's like no no they're my parents damn yeah it's true no they're just zombies or some shit they actually brought his parents back nobody's safe I don't know his old's better than iron fist Batman's dad is back and he is the Batman that kills yeah but that's a that's a different cinematic universe that's a different earth during that time batman's the one that's dead the recent boss with the iron fist off i think you got like a 12 or like a 15 damage buff he has the 2.7 uh there's one where whatever the mathematical equation my head's heard there's one where it does more damage it's more bad man's dead but his dad is alive it's on a the the anthill's not that good okay that was a lot easier to process agree to disagree let's go sorry y'all just figuring out a little bit too many numbers make head go shake
let's go today was supposed to be a short one off stream and then i started playing ring i could play ring for the rest of my life and i'd be happy
Happy is a very subjective raid.
Get over here.
There he is.
I'm gonna die.
But I'm in the back.
Left.
Oh!
We lost we lost Loki Were you though?
Were you actually healing me?
Oh my god, they can't hit their shots Were you though?
I can't get my fucking ship back up Why are you looking for a little?
They love it, try to make it Likely storm Oh
Uh, don't waste anything around.
They already cut.
Yeah, I'm not wasting them.
I'm wasting them.
I'm running.
I didn't even know.
Bolliter!
Okay, we can all let that be happening.
Why are we healing?
I can hold it.
I was healing him for the last second.
No!
No, you were not!
You were not.
You were not healing me on the last thing.
I looked at the replay!
I looked at replay!
Yeah, you were blocked.
I looked at replay.
I refused to play.
Pick and pick.
I looked at replay.
Oh no.
Oh no, I couldn't copy.
I got both supports.
Oh, we got no.
we're gonna be there our sports will spawn in first of course yeah i can try to alter okay okay push for now our sports are almost back you're not all you're not okay right that's your power oh my god i am ready to put on a show i am ready to put on a show okay he didn't get anybody their lunar ult will run out we have to i can i can use aggro run out okay look at hella look at
Oh my god!
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on!
Please!
I'm going to sue after this.
Oh my god, okay.
There's nothing I could do.
I'm going to...
I'm not going low key for this.
I can't, I can't survive.
Bro, we don't, can you go cloak or do you want my Luna?
What do I mean?
Luna cloak, Luna Sue is counter dive.
Does someone no more?
I can, I'm just not that good.
I don't know.
We don't need to, bro.
We don't need to.
Like, I'm just with the Loki, but the Loki was always trying to run away from it.
What do you mean?
I'll try to comment a little bit more and I'll protect them.
I was in front of you!
not your fault not your fault it's just every time i tried to come back and heal you you would walk the opposite way what that is a lie i was literally bro is lying bro is lying we all saw what's going up bro is actually lying on vc oh my god that doesn't make sense bro is lying on stream That's actually...
Should I give him until I can't afford to walk away?
We actually saw him!
I would run to him!
I was in front of him!
Bro!
What do you mean?
I would run away!
Look at him!
That's actually...
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Look at that.
That's just saying that I was running away from him.
I was in front of him.
How would I run away?
That's crazy.
We all saw it too, right?
I don't know what he's talking about.
We all saw it.
him not kill me in front of me?
How would I run away?
We go topside, let's just go topside, go top.
I'm not fighting, I'm not fighting this fucking time.
I just fell off.
Topside, topside, topside.
Why would you be by yourselves right now?
We all saw it on 4K.
It's fine.
Well, yeah, I mean, we all disappeared.
They're moving now.
It's actually crazy.
He was like, you're running away from me.
I'm like, how?
How do I run away?
Oh my god.
Well, uh, there's no accommodation at this point.
I won't disappear so easily.
Because I was like, I didn't see it because I was playing viral rather.
That's actually crazy.
I'm pretty sure it's just a team diff.
That is definitely a team diff.
Like he just watched he needs to watch the fucking replay.
I should have went invisible too.
Don't mess with the amazing spider!
I don't know.
Okay, we're gonna go.
Clearly you needed some help.
I have blue now, I have blue now.
I'm walking.
Touch.
It must have one point, it must one.
There's somebody behind me.
He's behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god.
On the left side.
Okay.
That's unfortunate.
I don't want to use my jump though, that's the thing.
I don't want to use my jump.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Oh my, get out of here!
Get out of here!
I can't jump, I can't jump, I can't jump, I...
There's nothing I could do.
Look at Luna, look at Luna, look at Luna.
Six seconds, five, four, three.
for sure we have one
Okay, that's fine.
We have to use this to live the hell out
Okay, we live we stacked We stacked see this is what you mean you gotta trust the process you have to stack when you're getting alted.
You don't run away.
You have to trust the process.
They're not strange.
They're not teleporting.
Yeah, sure.
Okay, I'm going to try and let the rocket heal because we need, okay, we got it.
Okay, I was worried that probably going to be on the top of the board, though.
I have my ult to go.
Can you get it?
Oh my god, wooply, dooply.
I won't lose ult to you, man.
I want him out.
up here i want him out of here don't worry hokey what if you go down you're gonna rest
okay it's okay we keep each other alive there we go nice i don't have fun there we go yeah sick we did it one last push
all right low key i was gonna tell this cap to hang up the shield but it started working so even when you can't see me i'll never hang up my shield free distraction bro bro you should bro i don't know what that spider-man had in him bro but he just kept following me specifically before you attack get ready you're trying to hit your shield like in uh like in uh civil war we switched to namor and he like started crashing out in all chat so there's he's on something oh last in your timeline yeah oh last no more no more pig oh my god i can't countering me i am the center of attention average apex legends we have three supports i have to communicate or don't yell at me fucking liar ass bitch running away i say as i stare at him indirectly in the eye like actually lying ass bitch
is you okay that'll be okay right yeah it's okay
oh my god i wanted to save him oh we use all our squirrels for that i don't think we call them holy shit how many of us okay i'm dead they popped a bunch there do we go back to dps and get rid of the triple support uh yeah i thought you wouldn't see me again i don't think any of us place dps
okay don't worry i believe we're still not fully together oh wait the other dps is mr fantastic if we go brawler
Okay.
Oh my god, technically we have four support outs if you think about it.
If you think about it, it's technically four support outs.
Am I healing anybody?
Is anybody getting healed right now?
Reach out of the fight for a bit.
yeah look at the look at the rocket oh no guys I don't think it's winnable anymore yeah I should have swapped off but I can't swap off anymore I can swap off Loki no actually no they're on bucky uh i have ulti for this fight if we can definitely touch so we're gonna make it back up
oh i think that was a good combo
that's crazy i don't even know tp It's gonna end soon.
Nice pick.
I'm still touching, I'm still touching, I'm still touching.
We're here.
There you go.
Bucky on the right, Bucky on the right.
I'm a half, I'm a half, I'm gonna put it.
Okay.
This is a little scary.
There's one as well.
Okay.
I have to I have to swap everyone look at it because I will shut it yep yep yep I don't know if I can play Loki though now that they're on Bucky you took I don't know it'd be smart to He's great, Vulti.
He's looking like he wants to.
No, no, no.
He doesn't.
He just needs to.
Do one, do one, do one, do one.
I'm trying so.
Oh my god, I kept him alive.
I kept him alive.
That's good pick.
Look at how nice you got a lot.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die to strange.
Oh no.
I tried so hard to keep you alive!
I got it.
Was it good?
Turn on me, turn on me.
Oh no.
Oh no, live, live, live, please live.
I can't shoot you back.
Spider-Man could help or anything.
You'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner
Oh my Nice, but they're all gonna focus you I'm poor, I've lived, I lived Rocket 1, Rocket 1 I don't know how I'm dead though Oh, goodbye I'm healing, I'm healing, oh my god It canceled our accident I'm on the rocket right now I got grabbed
This is it This is it No, no, no!
I live for so long!
Oh, hello.
We can't get off point though.
We can't get off point.
He actually can't get off point.
Are you serious?
I don't know.
There's two tanks in the back line.
Oh my god.
There's nothing I could do.
No!
Fuck it didn't matter.
Oh my god.
Literally, I come back just to get fucking harassed.
I come back just to get non-stop harassed.
Every time.
I'll do one more.
I'll do last game.
Okay, next game is last.
It was the Lunar's fault.
The Lunar, it was the Lunar for lying in front of everybody.
I do.
Next game is LG for me.
Yeah, next game is LG.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't end on a loss.
That's right.
That's why this next one is my last.
Can't believe it.
Fucking running away as he says as I look.
Got him dead in the eye.
Oh, yeah.
Fucking bitch.
Yeah, get that shit out of here.
Get that out of here.
I hate that sound.
I hate the custom sounds.
They just feel, like, so excessive.
As I bleed in his arms, yeah.
running away why did he look at you well you die yeah exactly i was like bitch who's running away
i am full of hate i am i'm a little ball of hate
okay who
am i gonna banish from this match ghostly staring at the guy and i'm like what do you mean you just didn't want to get targeted by dive after i swapped off of uh loki he's like no wait no don't don't leave don't swap off because then i'd get targeted and i'm like damn right get me out of here
All right, last game, guys.
Oh, man, I did not expect to stream this long.
I didn't even eat lunch yet.
I did eat my...
I want to make more spicy noodles.
Sorry, spicy noodles.
Can I...
Even though I have my pre-cooked meals, I'm like craving some more spicy noodles.
Sorry, I say it all the time.
I always...
It's like, I have a humor of a 13-year-old kid, and every time I'd be like, I'm going to make some spicy nudes.
I'm like, God damn, I love spicy nudes, but I'm talking about my bulldog noodles.
I'm talking about my bulldog noodles I always I just call him spicy nudes because I think it's funny
Never mind the noodles the bulldog noodles you're such a child
It's funny.
It's funny Oh, yeah, sorry can't be you can't you can't joke about of nudes anymore because unless unless you're 18 or up sorry europe i forgot about that that's crazy that they've been that they can't even watch porn i thought that was looking hilarious i was like bro what the fuck they're gonna hit puberty like these like bro those kids They're gonna hit puberty?
You're not stopping them.
You're- You're not stopping a teenager.
You're- Don't find a way.
You can't fucking ban that shit.
Don't find a way.
Like, yeah, exactly.
Like, how is that gonna stop them?
Oh my god.
I wanna do that so I can feel them better.
Jesus Christ, please, please, please.
Oh, backline, no.
Yeah, no fucking shit.
Where?
Oh, my God.
She wasn't looking at me.
She wasn't even looking at me.
I fucking... I see what you did.
I know what you did.
I know you didn't look.
I know you didn't look at me.
I know.
I absolutely know.
I know what you did.
My god, I can't live.
I might go rocket at this rate.
I might have to.
still won't you control oh my god i might have to i have many faces i will go rocket
how healing for my friends oh that's how i outnumber you
my information area keep going us yes the world hell unleashed I don't know how I live, like, please tell me.
Holy shit!
Okay, I was gaming there!
You have to admit, I was actually...
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, I need to tell you!
Look up!
Oh!
Never be a hero!
It's not worth it And she still didn't keep me up All that, why?
All that!
I saved the cloak and everything I can't believe it I actually saved him I can't talk even face me That's actually how you face me Oh my gosh Never be a hero Never be a hero It's not worth it.
It's not.
Gross A.
Never be a hero.
Just like the movie.
I literally...
God of lies.
If you wish.
What society?
I literally pull out the most massive save of my life.
I saved myself and I saved the cloak and I still die.
There's no karma.
Karma doesn't exist.
I...
I laid you on your back last game, little pup.
Pay the bottom.
You couldn't have barked yet.
I asked you.
You gotta do that for me, be the bottom.
I laid you on your back last game, little pup.
Go ahead and bark.
What is, what the hell is going on?
That's crazy.
I have many faces.
oh that's unfortunate i thought he was gonna be closer to it oh that's also unfortunate i legitimately thought he could be closer but he was absolutely not closer
oh my god he was gonna hulk smash and i got scared
I got scared.
Are they fighting or flirting?
It's Marble Rat.
Oh, that's...
You think...
You think he's okay?
It's okay.
We have our little clones.
If we save each other, it would be fine.
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
Please look at me.
Wait, we lost the control.
But look at me, please.
Oh my god, we live.
Okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
I had to use shift there, but there was no use.
Rock one
He's so young Please somebody save a cloak Oh, okay, that's awkward
Oh my god What the fuck?
Oh my gosh, I got extra power What's on me?
What's that on my body?
Oh, it's an explosive.
I hope he has...
He did not have a...
Okay, I was gonna be like, why did he go all the way up there?
I was a little concerned about that.
He's up.
Thank God.
Thank God we're okay.
We're okay.
Everything is okay.
I don't meant to did it.
Or I meant to not the Kno Kno Kno's.
Ah!
Out of anybody, Chico!
is that that one was personal that one was actually personal
that was like no no fuck her bro yeah like uh fuck her in general i kill it within the and we can't get point because our hell is terrible these days okay geez what is this You disgusting...
Y'all are horrible.
And you just got not to vent in zero.
Final strain.
Jesus Christ.
What is going on?
That was a crazy last game.
Wow.
I had a good time, guys.
I had...
That was...
Wow.
What a day.
That was fun.
I'm up to two more.
You're not a higher rank.
You're clearly not good at all.
Not on an alt account.
Stop yapping.
You're terrible.
Can Harley perform here?
Go check my profile.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
This is why I don't do rank.
This is why you live vicariously through me.
the um the essence of rank without having to actually suffer uh oh my god just kiss already all right he said check his rank all right where is his that name is so familiar isn't okay eternity one above all celestia so wait did he stop playing or did he got okay he oh okay He's been struggling.
That's okay.
Everybody peeks in high school.
That's me too.
I peeked in high school.
Look at me.
I went from...
Oh, I like that.
That's nice.
Wait, that's nice.
See, look.
I went from here.
And then...
And then we stopped.
We all fall off, you know?
We all...
It's okay, boy.
It's okay, bro.
Just like me.
The diamond one.
Yeah, it's okay.
It happens to everybody.
Guys, I swear, it happens to everyone.
That's why I'm back.
I'm back, baby.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
But wait, wait.
Before we need to watch, we have this was the thing we had to watch.
Where was it?
We had such a good streak and then this one was something.
Right here it was something else.
Where was it?
Where's Nom?
Was it here?
No.
It was here, right?
Was it with the coal train?
It was Central Park.
It was this, right?
Okay.
Here we go.
Is it here?
Okay.
Alright, let's watch the first instance of not.
Let's see.
It's like, where did brother go?
And I was like, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
All right.
And then the next one was like here, right?
Oh yeah, it was here.
Okay, it was here.
Pre-cap.
Brother here.
Alright, how did everything go wrong?
Okay.
Oh yeah, I had to kill here.
And then, there's me.
And then I was like, don't worry, guys.
And...
Where am I?
Wait.
Oh, there I am.
There I am!
I was like, leave it!
Let me go!
And I'm back here!
I see, I'm right here.
Right here.
Okay, here I am.
This is...
I am...
Right, okay.
Let me...
move back a little bit.
There we go.
Where am I?
Where did I go?
Where did...
There I am!
I'm right here!
This is where I started screaming!
And then I was like, get me out of here!
And then I snapped back here!
And then they turned around!
And then I killed him!
I killed him!
There he is!
That was a wild ride.
That really was.
Look at me go.
That was the whole...
There he is.
That was true.
At least I brought someone down with me at the end.
Can we have...
No.
I'm too mad.
He doesn't deserve it.
He doesn't deserve a POV.
You know what he deserves?
What was his name?
Where is this liar?
Oh, shit.
Shit.
You get to block for me.
That amount of people reported for lying.
Yeah, yeah, it should be reported.
I mean, like, he lied in VC because he thinks I couldn't defend myself.
Completely fair.
That was fun.
Whoops, let me eat it.
It's that really quick.
That's fun.
I had a good time.
The five hours pass by is so fast for me.
I don't know what.
I don't know.
Rink just does something to me where time pass by is super duper fast.
Whenever I play Rink, it doesn't feel like a lot of time has passed when I play it.
And then I look at the time and I'm like, oh my god, that's a long time.
Where the heck is my...
Oh, there's the chat.
There it is.
I'm going to call it here.
I mean, you know, making up for all the streams that, you know, digging from taking a vacation.
I hope you guys had fun watching.
Tomorrow is Battlefield 6 tomorrow, early access.
So, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.